[Music]
do
no
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
mmm
how i accidentally
became the biggest
chess streamer of all time me
how is that possible
oh please don't hurt me
oh my god
[Music]
don't worry
i'm down here
guys uh
i saw you big man hey
[Music]
i am not a chess streamer i don't know
what i'm doing
i was just trying to draw a line but
accidentally dragged that
am i dead
we can kill him
no what wait what
i want a refund
can i stop my wife
and as much cash as you can carry you
can keep i don't care if you put in your
pockets and your hoodie and your pants
and your shoes you know i still need to
whip out my camera and
put on
a smile
to get my picture taken
paul champs competitor here
oh my god
[Music]
hey guys welcome to thanks thanks for
the host
yeah moving the pawn out two squares hey
yo this move here is too rare he got the
two pawns out there as friends yeah
night came around yo we ready to end oh
my god the queen making moves already
yeah pull the queen out yo this dude is
heavy yeah and y'all know knights move
at the angle you stepping up the mag
then you straight
[Music]
welcome everybody to
pogchamps 4 presented by coinbase i'm
grand master robert hess alongside me
today my good friend anna rudolph anna
how you doing today
i'm doing great robert because finally
we have managed to make you spawn at the
scene of pakistan we have been talking
about you every single show i feel like
we needed you here
i've been hiding and it wasn't because
of you don't worry it's all danny don't
tell him i said that but i'm glad to be
here with you anna as we get into the
playoffs i mean it's been a really
exciting tournament thus far
it is going to be such an epic day let's
bring up the bracket of the consolation
uh championship shall we call it that
way the constellation bracket has plenty
of action going on today starting with
the match of just the mings against jake
and bake live and then we have mr beast
facing your boy harry mack
and also from the championship bracket
we're gonna see at the very end of the
day christine against fundy
of course some great matchups ahead and
before we talk about the specifics the
matchups we do want to note that puns
withdrew from the tournament has taken
an indefinite hiatus from streaming to
focus on his mental health we wish him
the best and that means that techtone
moves into the semis of the
constellation bracket where he'll await
the winner of harry mack versus mr beast
but as you said in addition to two
consolation bracket matchups we do have
a championship bracket matchup as well
there in the bottom left fundy versus
chris and you've been working with chris
so she has her work cut out for her
against the very strong fund who the
player is labeled as the top player in
the event the one that they expect to
win but i don't think that you're so
sure about that are you
no i'm so rooting for my girl chris it
is a tough match fonda is one of the
favorites to win pogchamps overall but
chris has improved so much that i think
she will put up a big fight today and
she could surprise fondly
for sure she was impressive in her
previous matches and speaking of
previous matches if you miss them we've
got the coinbase recap for you to review
the best moments from the day
you know what i'm just gonna take my
free piece
oh god i'm just going to take my free
case oh god shut up
what
so now i'm in chuck okay you are getting
crazy
i don't know if i made the right play i
don't know if i blundered i don't know
if i was doing something wrong but i
took my time there okay i did it
for her to lose so we can go in the pool
for sure
i know i want to go around the pool oh
we're going to the pool yes
yes
hey she's on vacation i don't blame her
close your eyes i just feel like are you
sure close your eyes do you think that's
a good idea yeah i think so that's hard
it might be worse than you are now okay
oh i'm just saying okay you got me there
i didn't win i didn't win guys i didn't
wait what i lied i'm not winning
oh
my god is this a celebratory
celebration that you survived
she won the match minx won the match
everybody we don't take the brook that's
the only thing you can't do
[Music]
sounds like arnold schwarzenegger we
have to get out of here get to the
chopper
you have to be careful he's doing the
wrong way
god
dude
come on
it wasn't the miss click who invented
that yeah
that doesn't make any sense this is why
this is good for me i have this defended
right now right
he goes here i can still go here and
then i have this entire line defended
and then he cannot cross it so it means
i win this pawn
wow i'm looking at this game by five up
and i'm ready to say
we have a new favorite to win the whole
event
oh my god
oh my goodness
wow
[Music]
uh i was asked that question earlier
today i do not have a bidet but if a
bidet was available and i needed to
[Laughter]
well guys we found out the true villains
of today
um file a very questionable doesn't use
a bidet danny we asked him quite a lot i
think what are you here did you just
turn off your camera
yeah it was a joke danny you're supposed
to end the stream and then yeah i'm
trying to do daddy i was also editing it
for you guys so i gotta do everything
well whether or not you have a bidet you
are more than welcome here and it was so
funny to relive those moments with some
impressive chess as well
exactly some of the most hyped exciting
and evaluation-bar dancing moments from
our group stage and today we will begin
both the consolation and the
championship brackets the matches will
start in a few minutes but before that
robert we do have a very important call
to action
we certainly do because chess.com is
happy to be supporting rise above the
disorder in their cause to remove the
two greatest barriers of mental health
care access and affordability started by
a world of warcraft guild leader in 2013
rise above the disorder has helped tens
of thousands of people all over the
world receive mental health care free of
charge go to go.chess.comrad
to make a donation and remember
chess.com will be matching up to 100 000
of the community's contributions it is a
great cause and we are very happy to see
everyone supporting it
so anna well we move on to the pairings
for today i always love these graphics
they're so well designed
which are you most looking forward to or
can you even choose just one
well i'm very biased as we are also
coaches for the tournament and two of my
ladies are playing minx and christine
are my students and friends so i'm
certainly rooting for them
but as we said chris for instance is
facing one of the overall favorites
fondy
minx is stuck in romania waiting for her
visa to get um finally approved so i
think she has unfortunately more
concerning things on her mind than the
chess moves
jake has come up with some amazing chess
terms i'm looking forward to some baby
forks and the rest of the crew and the
consolation bracket second match i'd
like you to talk about that match harry
mack versus mr beast robert you know
it's two great human beings in the
center there i can't really root for one
but i have been working with harry mack
his freestyle rap is unbelievable his
chest is getting there as well but i
have to give a shout out to chris
because i'm christine i think has been
maybe the most improved chess player
since the start of pogchamp so she has a
tough match in fundy but if she
continues her rise we could see an ups
in the making
that would be absolutely epic and yes
i'm super biased i am super biased
but we are also happy to see obviously
uh how much all of these players have
come through how much they have how much
effort they have put into improving
getting ready for their matches and with
chelsea who manages to move forward this
is already a knockout stage so the loser
unfortunately doesn't continue the
tournament and we certainly don't want
to say goodbye to anybody because you
know we look at the first match justin
minx and jake and bake live as you
mentioned the baby forks and justin minx
is always a fun person to watch she's so
creative and well sometimes a little
loud but we all appreciate it because
it's humorous and in good fun so i don't
want to say goodbye to anybody but today
september 9th is the day where people
must leave pogchamps 4.
and uh pogchamps is presented by
coinbase whether you're looking to make
your first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess and get
five dollars in bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account we'll be back
soon for the start of the match here in
the playoffs
game starts in four minutes here let's
go
can you pre-sell not like harry mack
i did not cover the body
right there baby
finish my breakfast
[Music]
let's go
get right back to sleep
[Music]
let's go
used to be in the rap game but now i'm
just here
strike game
thank you radcain for the 45 months dude
and mouldings are brand new what's up
i'm spending my food and then we're
going to start playing guys
listen boys let me tell you something
everybody melt up on your
get your together bounce
out
mirror dude boys at the mirror look at
that this could be you right here
gladiators
gladiators have that
they try to take everything from me
everything i'm still
mitchell's held accountable for
everything i've done and while
these people get away with i don't
i'm not fine
i still have nine red ones and i'm the
best
[Music]
three months
thank you for everything
signing out mitch jones
very nice
all right chap
getting in the chest maybe we're
starting to play
rich justin binks two games
constellation bracket game one if you
want me to move on if we don't i think
we're out we want to move on because
it's more money and more fame
racist luck
has to go in email mode i will hide the
chat
remember the to-do list control the
center develop the pieces castle checks
captures threats loose pieces fall off
watch out look out for your homies
always check before we move that we're
not we are our pieces defended
and look for oncoming threats
done
all right here we go
this is our time to shine baby
[Music]
all right
once it starts emote only i'm hiding
chat
love you guys chat and here we go
i'm hiding alerts i guess too
i muted alerts actually
[Music]
did we start
wait twitch
chess
[Music]
that was quite a half way to prepare for
the match by jake also minx is ready the
game is about to start but before we
head to the chessboard let me remind you
about all the platforms where you can
follow us on social media and especially
on discord if you want to win diamond
memberships our sponsor coinbase will be
giving out diamond membership for those
of you who join our discord and join in
on the discussion in the pogchamps 4
channel so make sure to join our discord
and also use the exclamation mark
contest command
absolutely yeah it's always good to be
in tune with the latest chess events
including pogchamps and while the format
for the bracket stage we know it it's
familiar to us but it is elimination
time so
the players they're used to ten minutes
and five second increment games and uh
the tie breaks that's where it gets
really scary right
it is heartbreaking as you said robert
we don't want to say goodbye to anybody
and yet that's what's happening today
today is the last day where we have all
participants showing up
and half of them will be gone basically
winner moves on loser stays at home and
the format the time control is the same
but if there's a tie break after the
first two rapid games we will have the
same sudden death blitz game with three
minutes and two second increment
and that's tough for these players who
are used to playing those 10 minute
games and more time to think then they
start freaking out because they look at
their clock where don't my time go it's
hard to make that adjustment for any
player and especially for the newer ones
but we're excited justin minx and jake
and bake live are about to start their
match up
anna your work with justin minx anything
special for today
unfortunately as i said minx has bigger
issues than her preparation she was
gonna travel to the u.s she has signed
with team envy and she has her full-time
contract but unfortunately her visa got
temporarily rejected and she's stuck in
romania so that's what she's currently
trying to sort out as much as we wanted
to meet up for a stream and more chess
lessons she unfortunately has been very
busy with the rest of the issues bigger
issues than the chess moves but i think
she still remembers our one and only
lesson take control of the center
develop your pieces and that's exactly
what jake said as well from his notes
and both players doing a good job of
that so far justin minks she's doing it
with pawns right she has this pawn chain
from c7 e5 and now brings out the knight
so it's a very good start for both
players and they're moving quickly
they are moving quickly that's important
to keep track of the time we also have
now the two players on camera and minx
is sporting i think a new headwear i
think i'm guessing that this is one of
the souvenirs she picked up in romania
it looks like a ram helmet or something
like that she's ready for a fight and
well i think jake is maybe not as
ambitious as he could have been there oh
you can't tell me yeah let's listen in
with minks and and uh
a little bit surprised by that move
bishop g5 a little taken aback
i'm not used to the silence
usually she listens to music and
dances and sings along this is a
surprisingly
silent moment
that's all right mix don't freak out
it's actually not that bad of a move
there's people next door are they
complaining
are they complaining
did they
who
the people
[Music]
no i was literally it freaked me out you
threw me off why would you lie
about that
yeah don't do that
dude mom
i was gonna lose anyway but now i'm
gonna lose earlier
well that was an unfortunate
moment of distraction ring scott ming's
got uh
i guess the ira issues to also also take
care of but in the end i think i think
everything is fine there i i wasn't
exactly sure what's going on with the
conversation her her mom was worried for
a moment but i think they are fine i
think this is an airbnb or hotel where
they're staying at in romania and it's
all right i mean just panicked for a
moment and lost her rook but it's not a
free rook for lucky for her that the
bishop could be captured so it's not the
best of trades but the rook wasn't
completely free
that's right and i felt like there was
an irl debate right like her mom debated
her and it reminded me of mom the
meatloaf where's the meatloaves that
it's very funny to uh hear that but it
seems like she is frazzled she was
trying to get off to a solid start and
really anna was that g6 move it left her
king's side very vulnerable and then she
couldn't quite fix it
yeah and the move g6 on its own wouldn't
have been a disaster i think it's just
that she was already freaking out and
the follow-up pushing the h pawn and not
realizing that the rook was hanging was
the main the main issue
exactly and
jake happy to take and maybe we can
listen to his thoughts
[Music]
okay that's right looking at this e5
push
in 95.
[Music]
good move though
wonderful classical music
[Music]
so focused
and jake finds the best retreat that was
the only way he could hold on to the
bishop
i need to get a queen here
maybe i should have moved here should
have moved there that would have been so
much better actually
nope never been so much worse
[Music]
still a good move uh how can i clear out
this guy
i like the way jake is thinking though
[Music]
full board awareness by jake and i just
want to show anna that the queen move
that jake i should have gone for was a
very bad one because queen h3 would have
been a botez gambit that bishop on c8
would have gladly taken that queen there
yes he's trying to get the queen close
to the black king understandable
but it's it's for the best for jake that
he ended up just dropping the queen back
to e2 to guard the c4 bishop i think
mink sins has chosen the ea square for
her queen and as jake said he wanted to
get rid of that knight or chase that
knight away from e5 he's pushing f4
great decision by jake because he was
noticing that makes his king is a bit
vulnerable and look at mince she doesn't
just react she doesn't say my knight's
under attack let me hit that queen
because if the queen moves anna down
goes the bishop on c4
that is an excellent mobile minks bishop
to g4 and that's why i was telling her
that she should have more confidence
because she does have board vision she
can spot moves like this even if she
didn't have much time to take lessons i
think she just simply has this instinct
for for one move could be potentially a
strong one so she found an intermediate
no bishop to g4 will she find a
follow-up that the bishop is hanging on
c4
irish
her mom entered the room we have her on
the screen here
cheers to chess i beat her twice today
she did you bet me twice a day and
you're awful my mom's so bad at it
just shows how bad she is
i know i'm bad i don't know you're not
she caught me two times mom i caught you
if you i i'm good at the star and then
i'm about at the end but i'm really bad
today
she's a check the uh checks captain he's
me
okay i don't know what's gone he's
freaking me out
see and if you didn't realize her king
was gonna be in big danger though
she
did and i think she
if she had a bit more confidence she
wouldn't have been panicking that this
is already bad stop losing
don't tell me what to do though because
that's cheating
okay
okay okay
no no no not commentate but i thought
you wanted to hang because you
seemed to want to hang but just
i felt bad for yelling at you because
you me over
oh
well call me john joe and pick
my pony
honestly i want to give her my job as a
commentator this is amazing
i cannot see that move along the way
there's a lot happening on the board and
with the commentary as well both of
these players obviously are hilarious
jake has given us some accent chess
terminology and minx is just overall
whether she's doing well or whether
she's losing she's always extremely
funny with her commentary on what's
going on she has just played bishop to
f8 and
this move could go well or could go very
bad depending on what jake does here
yeah the bishop was doing an important
role of defending the knight so now the
queen which is under attack can scoop
off that night but it was a good
defensive instinct so she recognized she
even said it oh my king is in danger i
need to help out but if we just go back
a few moves taking that pawn on f5 uh a
few moves back that's what actually made
her king even worse whereas the bishop
on c4 had been hanging for a while
and what's happening currently is that
jake did not realize that the knight on
f6 was hanging he gives a check on g5
and minx finds the blocking move bishop
to g7 funnily enough the f6 knight is
still hanging but this is now a lot more
difficult to spot and jake does it jake
sees it now there's a pin on the g file
exactly so good vision good full board
awareness by jake now to take that
knight although it's at the end of the
story right because this knight e5 can
still take the bishop on c4 and it's a
bit messy
let's listen to jake and see what he
thinks about this moment
okay
you checked me to put me in a fork but i
think i can just take what do i take
with
all right knight i guess i want to leave
that pawn down there
i don't want to open up my
thing too much and i can also take his
bishop if he takes
that
all right
let's see here so he can't move this is
pinned right here so we can't take this
um
what can i do here
[Music]
um
i see what i need to do
i see it
[Music]
um
well
[Music]
beckham let's listen to what mink says i
think she's realizing that this is very
dangerous
i don't know what's the safe thing here
she's not seeing the oh she's about to
give a bishop
if i eat him
she eats him she forgot that she's in
check no i don't know what to do here oh
he's in checkmate so i can't move him
no he's cornered there
i don't understand
grab the rook
remove one of the attackers
this isn't over jake has also missed
that the rook was hanging so he took the
bishop but missed that with that
discover check the rook will be captured
and he pretty much had that pre-move
like he was taking that bishop but she
didn't see that in fact she could have
taken his bishop because bishop takes f7
the bishop on h5 could have retreated
and captured but she moved her king in
the correct direction she said i when it
trapped in the corner so she moved
towards the center and then grabbed this
rook which jake did not see was hanging
but still he's up two pieces the black
king is in some big danger here and he
has so many more pieces to join the
party this knight can come to d5 this
knight to g5 and unfortunately for minks
it seems like he has too much firepower
yes it's indeed a very promising
position with the two extra pieces even
more so obviously for the attack but i
think at pogchamps this is something
that we have seen continuously at every
edition that things can turn around it
may look completely winning but it's not
over till it's over
and jay could still go wrong as well
basically jake i think he has been
playing really well in his group stage
games as well but he wasn't handling too
well the time pressure so i think what
he should avoid for today is to not go
too low on time he has been making a
conscious effort to speed up but even
like this obviously you don't have time
forever and the last few minutes can be
more difficult for him that's true so
now i think he lost every game but he
was playing really well against ludwig
in the first game he won that bishop i
remember his queen yeah uh swung from
the queen side over the kingside to win
a piece and right now he's playing
excellent chess bringing this knight
into g5 and here it is finishing off
the
juicy check
you see one juices check does he see the
other one on e6
i think he's taking your
guidance into account he needs to play
more quickly but he had a big fork on e6
instead yeah there was no baby fork that
was a royal fork
i should get queen here unless he moves
[Music]
oh i love this song good choice jake
hey
okay doing okay on time
oh let's see let's just say he moved
where'd he move to
does he always listen to classical music
anyways
he mostly does yes
it's quite the contrast when you have
minks today i don't think she has a
playlist prepared but she often would
listen to something very hype and upbeat
can you bring this rook out
[Music]
a great move
uh is there better i can make this let
me think
[Music]
i should get my rook dude
okay
this is
yeah
still extremely strong the attack of
course but he could have won the queen
again just can't how do i get this queen
dude
damn i actually messed that up i think
the problem when you have so many good
pieces that they take the squares of
your other pieces like that queen wants
to be where the knight on g6 is
exactly and if we just show for one
moment what was the fork that jake
missed it seems that that's his blind
spot in this game the e6 square is what
he had for his night already now for the
second time in the game and i would have
won the queen that's what he wants he
was talking about how to get to the
queen and then he missed this chance
yeah it would have been a devilish
tactic there and instead goes knight g6
which is a good move and and as i was
saying right like you want to play queen
takes knight on g6 to give a big check
but you can't take your own pieces so he
needs to figure out how to get out of
his own way
and will he do that he thinks that he
has messed it up a little bit will he
realize that he still has time with
these extra two pieces to regroup his
pieces retreat the knight and free the
space for the queen or bring his rook
into the game because that rook from a1
is still out of the action
ryan he's been talking about it so bring
the rook to f1 as you're saying anna
helps protect the knight also brings
another attacker into the game so he
just needs to get this right but his
time is ticking and he's down under
three minutes and you've mentioned
that's when he struggles
yes i'm afraid that if he doesn't speed
up now okay he chooses knight to d7 and
that's still rather fast
let's see if minx will move the rook
away and if so what square she chooses
for the rook
just hovering over
it's it great choice
excellent indeed attacking the queen and
the bishop ii needs to be guarded as
well as the d7 knight is depending on
the white screen protection
and now
jake is down under two and a half
minutes so if he's trying to be a
perfectionist
now might not be the time because he
really is
losing the clock
let's listen in with his stream as well
and
see what he thinks
great move
[Music]
dude i'm
so confused right now
all i need to do is get this bad boy out
i just
i don't feel like i've had a turn where
i can actually get it out
wait a second
[Music]
maybe this is the turn jake was talking
about will he bring the rook in
something is going on here and i can't
figure out what it is
it's got a good sense though that
there's something going on
good choice the rook is out all right i
can't definitely can't lose on time here
i have a rook following my queen file
now which is very good
i think i'm set up here well
the her queen is just very scary to me
everything's defended all my homies are
defended
that's what he has in his nose
the homies for extra defense
by attack i think this is it
okay
great decision this is everything still
defended
[Music]
yeah just a few moves away from
checkmate and the fumes could literally
be
one move if jake spots checkmate in one
okay that should be queen i guess
or go here
[Music]
oh
oh no
oh my god i didn't see it
let's swap to minks as well i think she
is just face filming in this very moment
realizing that her queen is now hanging
me
me dude
dude jake's good jake did end game two
okay you know what you know what chad
i'm correct
i'm correct i'm better at this when i'm
drunk
i'm better at this
anna well i guess next time for coaching
if you can't you know meet up for
sessions you need to send her a bottle
of something to help her out
it's it seems that minx needs to get
their confidence but she wasn't doing
poorly she just doesn't believe
sometimes that she is capable of playing
at a higher level because all of her
opponents in the group stage and also
here are higher rated than than she is
but that bishop was hanging on c4 for a
while and they both missed it at the
final phase though
i think this was perfect play by jake uh
he just brought in all the homies they
were defending each other and then
beautiful checkmate he didn't even take
the queen he just was queen to h6
instead of capturing the free queen
kind of the perfectionist it seems he's
always looking for the better move it's
why he gets in time trouble but he's
nearly 900 and he might be a favorite to
win this consolation bracket if he keeps
it up
indeed and i think before we head over
to the second game we will give you guys
a short break but we will not leave you
with that entertainment mixes analyzing
her game on her stream right now
music that was there for ages
yeah they're really calling me
out they're like no
just think what can i talk before you
move do you play ironically
i wish i actually don't know what that
means
let me smash
noel banks in 2001 made it rain with 10
euros can you call schlatt to say he is
handsome and should make only fans
no i'm trying like not to lie as
much this trip has made me a better
person
you still get 3k though what does that
even mean
3k points
is that how many people found me
no
no 3k usd
i've not won one game what the do
you mean i win 3k
what
oh
i love chests so much oh my god
i love chess oh my god bring me back
next year are you serious
are you serious oh my god
oh my god okay
now i need hype music um
i love chess so much
so much okay right i'm gonna run to
toilet really quickly uh before the next
game
i love chess
i love chess so much
so much i love chess
please
oh my gosh
[Music]
all the homies were being looked out for
in that game
all right
this is a big game baby
[Music]
okay
come on check i got chest weave and
nemo's training on my side
i said they're taking a short break i'm
just i'm a little shaky a little nervous
a little
nervous
maybe i need some warm-up music
from my hit k-pop single according to
wikipedia
[Music]
scrolling through my phone i see the
notification
my queen came online time to us and uh
nation
12 month here
and bid leader
still praying one day that i might get
to meet her
patreon
[Music]
one day she'll
be
[Music]
own streaming history while supporting
your favorite gamers and streamers by
buying their digital collectibles on
eternal
collecting these sometimes hilarious
always epic gaming and irl highlights
directly benefits the creators while
providing you the fans something unique
and special to keep
sign up on eternal.gg build your own
collection and feel the thrill of
ripping digital packs and viewing
amazing moments in the marketplace
[Music]
and i'm not quite sure what that pump up
song is but it seems to be working for
jake he's in the lead 1-0 over justin
minx
pretty good first game there by jake i
must say he was bringing in all the
homies
that was the key he talked about it and
he did bring in and defended all the
homies it was a great work between the
minor pieces and the queen he didn't
even take the free queen at the end of
the game because he spotted checkmate
that was a beautiful finish and now the
players are ready for the second game
minx needs to win this second game with
the white pieces to tie the score and
earn the right to a blitz
tiebreaker and well the game is getting
underway minx in her ram hat i'm not
sure she knew the game was starting
because she seemed
pretty
it's not so easy to run a stream from
one laptop that's why we constantly see
her obs as well i think we see her
drinking too
yeah she did say that probably was
missing from the first game um i think
she had a drink in her hand
during the first game but she was taking
it light i think
all of her comments obviously need to be
taken
as a lot of time just joking and with
irony including when she's complaining
about her mom because she she and her
mom have a really good relationship
oh we definitely will need to ask her
both about the grape juice she's
drinking and how she feels that her
mom's debating her earlier
she's got the development right she
already has one point in the center
developed her king side and caused
everything as we learned at the lesson
this is not okay to do he freaks me out
with that
i don't like this move he does he did
this last time and it threw me off
he did this last time and it threw me
off
copying him dead-ass copium
let's listen with jake as well and see
how he feels about this position
under any threats
he's our time wisely don't let time okay
he's moving rook out interesting move
there not quite sure
a little interesting
i'm gonna castle
[Music]
well jake realized that the accomplish
of minx was not the best choice here
with that night hanging
yeah he hasn't mentioned it yet
we need to focus on what changes with
every move we make and that pawn was an
important defender
[Music]
oh he moved already what the heck
but that's actually bad for him because
he doesn't even probably realize what
the last move was that's true
[Music]
even if it's highlighted slightly then
b3 square
[Music]
any grabbing pieces that are not
oh gosh i think we should uh
show everybody
what the mistake was there and actually
it was just having a second time and now
jake oh he was like sort of encouraged
to find it because if we just go back
and come with anna the move b3
left this knight hanging and
jake didn't take it the first time and
then when you play a3 the bishop has to
move but somehow he wasn't thinking
forward he's just retreating and what
goes on you think in the players minds
to retreat rather than
take a piece in the forward direction
i'm not sure i would have i would have
predicted that jake was gonna spot it
after his bishop was forced to move i
think the first time that he didn't see
it was understandable since he didn't
even notice it was his turn and he
wasn't paying attention to what was the
last move of minx
but it's it's i think more surprising
that he didn't see the second time rings
were shocked for a moment there but her
night has survived and she has gained
quite some space on the queen side this
is now looking better for white not much
of course but it's important that the
knight is safe
absolutely those pawns they march
forward the bishop doesn't look very
good on b6 it's staring into a pawn
chain so not very good news for that
piece that could have taken a knight for
free and you're right i think part of it
was that he didn't even know that it was
his move but also sometimes i think
newer players they struggle to
attack and go forward because they're
worried about are they doing the right
thing and that was a moment that i think
jake will regret when he analyzed the
game
possibly possibly and speaking of that
i'm looking forward to the next match in
a sense that mr beast is one of the
factions players that always that
surprises us with his creativity when it
comes to his pieces being attacked he
usually counter attacks instead of
moving his pieces he's the opposite
which is a good attribute to have
because instead of just reacting every
single time to be creative and come up
with threats of your own that is cool
but unfortunately i think for mr b
sometimes he needs to reel it in a
little and
for makes she moved her night out it's
not a terrible move it's fine she's
offering a bishop trade and jake needs
to see that this bishop is attacked
twice not just once and is only defended
a single time
let's listen
with jake now and see if he feels the
danger will he trade the bishops or
defend it
what are they looking to do capture this
[Music]
now let's see do i give this up
for the sole purpose
of my next move
so see i moved here he was here
i move here guaranteed rook
i think i'm going for something juicy
going for something juicy here
oh no i blundered take the bait take the
bait take the bait take the bait take
the bait
take the bait
take the bait take the bishop
i know you want it you
want the bishop
it's so juicy it's just hanging the
bishop's hanging why wouldn't you take
the bishop
it's just chilling right there there's
no reason not to take the bishop
right guys
yes knotters
yes
why wouldn't i take the bishop exactly
any moment
the bishop will be taken
which i don't know if it's actually that
good of a move but it didn't move
let's doesn't even mings and see the
pieces she's clicking on is it the
bishop
of the knight
that's a great move by mix in the taking
the night she could have even taken with
the other night but that was more
difficult to see
that is her sub notification roberts uh
is it
yes
i was going to say some people sneeze on
the truth others belch oh i need more
i'm not sure jake has expected this
capture it would have even it could have
been even better with the other knights
so that the knight on g5 wouldn't be
hanging right now but mingx just
continues capturing the pawn it's an
extra pawn
[Music]
some great decision making by minx i
mean she said that she needed a drink
would help her chest and i have to say
i'm not encouraging it
but she's playing better this game
she has taken that free pawn we could
show it just for a brief moment that if
it was the other night that captures
first and jake goes for the same
response then she would have ended up
winning the bishop as well
but it was not that simple to see and
there could have been an intermediate
move with the capture on it too so it
was a very messy position for a
pogchamps match it's normal that neither
of the players could calculate it with
clarity
uh but in the end minks went for the
safe decision capturing twice on e4 and
is up a pawn
she is and she moves her night away it
was just under attack so honestly she's
playing really really well with the
exception of leaving this knight on c3
under type before but i it was a mistake
she moved on and her play is great in
fact her pieces are much better than
blacks the bishop on b6 isn't doing that
much and she retrieved her night out of
danger she is up a clear extra pawn
i would love to hear her thoughts and
also check back in with jake later on if
he if this is debate he was hoping for i
don't think so
very different styles music
oh
[Music]
his queen is freaking me out i don't
move i don't move
[Music]
i think that's another great move to
gain more space on the queen side and
ask this night where do you want to go
there aren't too many squares for the
night available and i wonder what jake
is thinking where to move it now we see
his arrows
that's the question right now
um
i don't want to retreat yet so i'm going
to try to move there and see how that
goes
i still like to get this out so now
she's trying to bring this out i don't
know let's see
pretty even on time here
i want to get this out and then push
this pawn that's like my strap that's
like the the the idea i have in my head
that's what i want to do
because that way that is a great time oh
yeah if she takes a day queen if she
doesn't take i take and i'm moving onto
little baby forks and we trust me we
know we want those baby forks oh boy do
we want baby forks
it's all based on what she plays here
she has a lot of moves actually she has
a
i mean shoot she has a no
she has moves i mean i think she does
have some pretty much right here put my
bishop in
[Music]
you know if she moves here
crap that's really good i think
that's actually a really good move uh
i don't think i have any options for
that okay let's just us that's that
might be our best move that's really
good actually holy crap traps my bishop
so she was there what do we do
oh this is great the way he's thinking
about the game is wonderful
his idea to bring the rook to the d-file
and then push the pawn is excellent to
attack the center of white and noticing
that there's a pin on the d5 he's
slightly worried about the knight jump
if minx plays knight to a4 um but in
reality it's not an issue because his
bishop is protected by both pawns
and minx makes a good move with the
bishop to f3 attacking this pawn on b7
but she needs to notice
the knight does protect the square i
have to say the fact that jake is sort
of reversing the board and thinking
about his opponent's plans is not
something we see from all of the
pogchamps participants so it's really
nice to see that that's how you're
supposed to think about chess and he's
doing a great job and mink's really
she's performing so much better this
game anna
oh like is it
i'm gonna stay silent um it's your show
now anna
all right uh minx you okay there why did
he do that did you have a plan i was
going for this piece here
i was going for this piece
how about jake is he noticing that he
can just take it
off
okay
i think jake is about to click on his
knight
wow
just when things realize jake chooses
the knight to capture the bishop
open
because she didn't even look she knew
what was going to happen to her bishop
wait but 94 is a really good move by her
it's what jake very strong strategic
move indeed that knight is heading
toward the c5 square she did not lose
the piece jake didn't capture on c6 with
the pawn but i'm just hoping that she
realizes it because she noticed that her
bishop was hanging in the end by the
pawn the pawn could have taken it
and she was holding
her face in her palms when the move
happens i'm not even sure that she
realized in between that it wasn't the
right capture by jake
and jake was fixated on freeing his
bishop which is why he played that c6
move to begin with but this is danger
zone for minx because the bishop on c7
if jake knows what a battery is and
brings the queen to d6 that could spell
checkmate on h2 in the near future anna
let's listen in with jake and see if
that is his idea the rook went back
to
a1 it's a mysterious choice
pause
chip take a second
attack her only defense is this right
[Music]
and if she does this what do i do is the
question
do i attack it
[Music]
needs a
stonewall lesson from cutie cinderella
play f4
oh my god
[Music]
there it is baby
we found a little sneaky attack over
there let's go
wow
oh my god
all right bring up the alerts
wow that came out of the blue that
checkmate queen age for setting up the
attack on the h2 square and mingx didn't
realize how dangerous it was i think she
was freaking out from the queen but
didn't fully understand how much she
should have been freaking out
i think they left us with an easy choice
for the play of the game presented by
eternal.gg because it was just happened
right now in the last few moves anna
where knight a4 was a good choice by
minx but jake seeing the bishop was
under attack he thought that bishop
could get trapped returns it to c7 and
anna i mentioned cutie cinderella her
opening play with the f4 move would shut
down that bishop but after rook a1 queen
age 4 unfortunately minx just didn't see
it coming
yes maybe ming should have had another
session with cutie they are very close
friends but i think because of the
travel issues and such minks didn't have
time for chess and
it showed that jake played
really well today excellent just in the
first game in the second game he clearly
deserves to move on to the semi-finals
and who knows as you said maybe now we
have a new favorite for the consolation
bracket
he played extremely well honestly i was
very impressed by the way he was
thinking not just about his ideas but
what she could do to stop his ideas even
in this last moment here was it okay i'm
threatening checkmate she should stop it
so maybe she'll play h3 and he was
talking about the bishop takes h3
ripping the king open so that the queen
could swoop in with the bishop and the
queen aiming at that square once more so
that was anna i think a really
impressive performance by jake
excellent game the only moment where he
didn't realize that he had something was
a few hanging minor pieces the c3 knight
and earlier the c3 knight and later the
c6 bishop but overall he put together a
very strong attack and clear ideas so
that was a very impressive play
and i think because this was impressive
this would be our choice but we also
want to know what is your choice for the
eternal play of the game you only need
to sign up at eternal.gg and connect it
with your twitch account that's
literally a few second call to action to
go to eternal.gg connect it with your
twitch account and from then on you can
type in eternal in the chat every time
you see a moment that you think should
be eternalized what happens with the
winners uh robert please tell us about
what can people take home and what can
they order
yeah well the play the games that
receive the most votes will be turned
into digital collectibles and dropped on
september 12th with all proceeds going
to rad charity dedicated to making
mental health accessible so three lucky
viewers who voted will win a free pack
and we'll announce the winners and of
course you can pre-order the pog champs
four
packs containing epic moments from this
tournament including those voted by you
there's a limit of three thousand packs
they're going fast three packs per user
so sign them now with your twitch
account and watch out for more info on
voting to turn play of the game into
eternal packs you can win
that is indeed three winners per every
match so there's a lot of chance to win
but if you don't want to just leave it
to
a bit of randomness do order the packs
as soon as you can because as robert
said it's a limited edition and most of
them are gone already we only have a few
hundred samples left a few hundred packs
and all of the proceeds will go to
supporting rise above the disorder our
charity absolutely well we are going to
short break so we can bring the players
in for a postmatch interview and in the
meantime enjoy harry mack freestyling
some awesome rap
so yeah
access about a thousand total we're sold
less than that like 950 or something
like that
it was crazy way more than we thought we
would maybe sell a hundred so shout out
to everyone who supported the brainwave
all right let me make sure my chest uh
yes i'm definitely going to keep playing
chess after pog champs in fact that's my
favorite thing about pogchamps if you've
been following me in pogchamps you know
that i have yet to win a game
in the competition i've lost uh five
games and and one was a draw
so there you have it but um
i feel like i've won
and it's not because i'm delusional and
lacks self-awareness although i'm sure
uh i i do to some extent lack
self-awareness as most of us do but um
no the reason i feel like i'm winning is
because i have developed a true and
genuine interest in chess and i actually
really really enjoy playing i really
really enjoy learning about it it's been
awesome to be able to
study privately with uh with robert hess
the grand master himself
he's a really really great mentor
and teacher
and so yeah i'm gonna keep uh you know
well i'm saying now that i'm gonna keep
going with chess and i'm saying it so
that i can hopefully hopefully you all
can help hold me accountable because i
don't want to let go of this chess thing
i don't want to only do it because the
pressure's on now i actually want to be
a chess player man i'm really digging
the game it's so cool
i have not watched queen's gambit
i know it's like sacrilegious to say
that and to be in this competition like
that would be the bare minimum right at
least watch the show everybody loves the
show i know that i would love it i don't
watch a lot of television these days um
but i do want to make time for that
mr beast is quite good god damn scary
very scary i'm on chess tv now my god
what up chess tv
we here
getting ready for mr beast uh getting
ready for mr beast yeah yeah yeah mr
beast are you ready for this competition
understand hmac is on a mission yeah
imma flex on songs imma do a little
shout out to chess.com every time i
rhyme i'm sitting in my god stance it's
an honor for me to be here at park
champs yeah i bring the thunder flames
truth told i haven't yet won the game
but today we bout to solve this mystery
h mag spitzer free live here with mr
beast yeah hey yo my skills they be
vital me and mr beast we about to go
viral yeah and money the world really
needs this but will mr beast be
philanthropic with pieces i don't know
i'm really trying to claim them every
time i'm rhyming the instrumental i'm
flaming yeah and y'all know we about to
get it done to be honest i'm just in
this session having fun we'll see how
far we take it my lyrics may be sacred i
keep it honest all the time you know i
never fake it let's really go i come off
top with the ellie flo fourth game y'all
know that we out here spitting more
flames yeah hey yo we about to get it
done heart and soul couple places that i
spit it from
yeah will i go pawn to e5 hmac bout to
die why do rappers even try got the
knight coming at the right angle with my
pieces
welcome back everybody we have both
players in for the interview thanks so
much for joining us and well jake i have
to start with you that was a very
impressive display you brought all your
pieces together and delivered the
knockout blows how did it feel
it felt good you know i had a couple
homies back there on the back lines
couldn't forget about them you know
throughout the whole process and without
them i wouldn't be here today but uh no
actually there was a many times during
the games with minks i was like
i was i don't know if you guys kyle's
like come on take the little bait or
like take the like don't see it please i
was like rely on come on
but uh
the first game was super scary actually
i was like okay i'm ahead like this is
cool i'll get in the corner and then she
she played like every move she did i
have to go and analyze or whatever but
like i was like holy oh my god my back's
up against the water now i actually
might lose
all my pieces right now i was actually
so terrified
did you feel it
you know the first half because i was i
don't know if you tuned in but i was
yelling at my mom because in the first
thing and i won't i thought i was moving
off the side that wasn't the king
because she had told me the hotel
neighbor was complaining um
but she was like they're saying like if
she's playing chess you know that isn't
okay she's being too loud so i'm like
looking i'm like what do i i can't get
kicked out here because everything's
gone wrong she goes on for five minutes
then she goes i'm kidding and i was like
i blamed her for losing but also i would
have lost regardless but at the start
you mom
break you mom but no no
the end game was insane that last game
caught me off guard and that's when i
realized that i had no chance against
him no i really thought in the end game
i had it
like in confidence i thought i was doing
good and then out of nowhere checkmate
popped up and i had a moment where i was
like i don't understand what happened
here this is lag might have been a
glitch in the system we could go back
and analyze
yeah it means we did catch the irl
debate that happened honestly props to
your mom because she played you pretty
good
she did she did i don't know it's the
fact that like we already got removed
from a hotel due to stuff so i really
believed it was happening again with bad
luck and i'm like i can't deal with this
right now not right now not with chess
yeah i'll have to pay play your mom
later for distraction she'd definitely
help me out
i was gonna say if your mom is on team
jake because it felt like that
yeah mom and then actually mom come here
real quick she said at the end i showed
her the the finishing move that jake did
yeah and she said she was just like oh
you're just stupid
she didn't even like try to
so i blame my mom
i'm sorry
hi hi minx's mom
how you doing okay you can go now no get
off me let me lose oh okay sorry
oh whoa hey hey
well jake you do have a new fan i
believe and and minx i know that there's
a lot going on with your travel so it's
difficult to focus on a chess match when
your visa got temporarily denied so we
hope the best for the process and that
you managed to make it to the us and
don't get stuck in romania
yeah yeah no i'd love to blame it on
that but i've lost every match since
yeah i i will say i like all the people
i played
jake was like literally the one i
struggled the most against i believe i
thought i'd be snap nap i feared but
jake you in the twitter thing he was
like don't worry i have won one
you had it from the start of each game
and then you can you check me like you
checkmate both games that's so
impressive
thank you i've never seen minks this
wholesome i don't know how to react guys
she's very awesome in reality and she
loves her mom i just i just i want to
clarify because not everybody
understands minx's humor that she has a
very good relation with her mom thinks
is my homie
yeah yeah my mom's my best friend
today
okay
well jake you're moving on i mean it was
your first match win how you feeling now
that you've got a victory under your
belt and continuing on in the
constellation bracket
well it takes a little bit of blood
and let's just say i'm ready to
cannibalize
that sounds very promising for the
semi-finals and last but not least jake
about that preparation because i i know
it means very well uh we have been
bodies for a while uh but your dance i
think you wanted to outperform minks it
was mink so far who has been singing and
dancing for during the games or before
and this time makes you miss the show
that jake was all in
yeah how'd you get the blood flowing
so so you were dead usually i danced to
distract from how bad i am at the game
so man destroyed me and was dancing so
we got the double flex going on okay
okay jake i'll be you monopoly next time
we'll have a room
before the game it was the preparation
then during the game jake was super
focused you're trying to play monopoly
all right we'll talk later not big man's
coming for
you well whether it's monopoly deal or
chess you two are both always a great
time so thank you so much for joining us
really appreciate it and jake we'll see
you again soon for your next match thank
you thanks all the best for your trip
good luck
good luck in your matches jake thanks
for having me again guys
of course
that is a potential monopoly rivalry
rising and also the dance i'm telling
you i'm telling you robert that was
that was epic the preparation of jake i
should have asked also what was that in
that ball it felt like he was munching
on a ball of cereals while dancing and
rocking out
it is currently minx was rocking out on
her stream that is her be right back
that i saw for a second i have both
streams still open but we have no
time to waste because we are here also
for a very important cause that is our
charity
initiative we are supporting rise above
the disorder please do donate if you can
every single donation will be matched by
chess.com up to a hundred thousand
dollars rise above the disorder helps
tens of thousands of people to get
access to mental health for free and
this is such an important cause we want
to make sure that everybody is aware
that if you use the command exclamation
mark red or click on the donate button
you can contribute every single
pennymatters and chess.com is matching
every single donation so thank you so so
so much to everybody who has helped so
far
yes we really do appreciate it it is
making a world of difference so thank
you so much and i do see tech tone
in the chat saying come on mr beast i
don't know how harry matt's gonna feel
about that but we're gonna go to break
because when we return we'll start with
a matchup between mr beast and harry
mack coming up shortly
five minutes out
all right we'll switch off the emotes
what's popping y'all
a random guy you bet all your points on
me oh my god as though i didn't already
feel pressure
can i tell new viewers what's going on
yeah yeah yeah i'm about to be in pog
champs y'all
i've been in pog champs
unfortunately i didn't win any of my
games
in the uh in the first leg of this
so um
you know but but luckily
uh there's a bracket for the losers
and i am in that bracket
and uh
it turns out that mr beast
is a loser as well
um not generally speaking he's he's
pretty much
as much of a winner as anyone could ever
hope to be
um
in terms of having one of the biggest
youtube channels in the world and uh
changing people's lives for the better
on uh on a very consistent basis so
shout out to him but in pogchamps
it appears as though we have both uh
lost and now we find ourselves playing
each other
as uh as losers to see who will win
uh in the losers bracket so
um it's very exciting
obviously i have a tremendous amount of
uh
of respect for uh for mr beast so no i'm
not gonna roast beast
but uh yeah that's what's going on i am
in pog champs playing against mr beast
the mr beast
okay
hey gms
thank you man can't root for anyone
because you're commentating of course
much love appreciate it man thank you
for your guidance
trying to hold it all in my mind here
we'll see
shout out to gm hess man incredible
incredible human being great teacher
best mentor i could have asked for i've
been playing chess for about a month now
i guess
um
and uh yeah you know it's been uh it's
been awesome i'm very excited about
chess truly
i'm gonna keep playing even after this
competition
revenge of the prawn said can't believe
you're nervous you must not have seen
any of my other games
i've been very nervous for all of them
no but i'm here to have fun man it's
gonna be dope
how long until you're playing him it
should be in just a minute here
the prediction is that chandler ruins it
somehow wow
harry is the king listen up you pawns
all right we should be about there
so
bong cloud is the best opening move in
chess i don't i don't think that's true
from the context clues but i don't know
what bon cloud is
okay they say emote chat win in game i'm
gonna do it now cause i just got
notified i think we're close all right
emote only
it's coming soon
wow
oh wow
thank y'all for supporting me through
this journey by the way
it's been awesome
i've gotten a lot of love from the
community
it's been really dope
shout out to this dancing octopus
squid my apologies
and shout out to this hype yoda
slight delay here mr beast is getting
seated okay oh my god he's in the
building
he's getting situated
wow no idea what to expect
as always
but i'm gonna try to bear in mind
the key principles
as i understand them
develop my pieces control the center you
know
double check to make sure i'm not gonna
and before hair is matched against mr
beast begins let me remind you that we
do have a one week free trial both on
ios and android available for learn
chess with dr wolf dr wolf is the next
best thing to an ira coach it could be
your next virtual chess coach if you
want to improve it will have everything
you need
for your further progress and as i said
it's free one week free trial both on
ios and android not as good of a coach
as robert has i must say because mr
robert has is the coach of harry am i
correct robert
you are correct but i don't coach and
tell so i can't give you any more
information than that uh harry's been
working hard he's been making tremendous
strides i'm excited because mr beast i
have to give him full credit because
he's looked really good in some of these
matches his first game against ludwig
that was beast's immortal
that game i felt like is the game that
we recall as mr beast has won the match
um it's not the case because there was a
tiebreaker and ludwig won that
tiebreaker but he did come with a 20
move long preparation that prepared by
mr daniel is it why dany is not here
today by the way robert do you think
it's a prep battle between you and him
again
i hope not because
you know
i just want them to have a good time no
more prep bass not about the coaches
about the players uh but i am excited to
see this matchup because i think harry
really has improved and his rating
belies his strength because it's like
200 something he's way way way better
than that and if he can find his form
his confidence he can go toe-to-toe with
mr beast who has looked so much better
in this pogchamps in the previous one
it's clear that he has progressed as a
chess player
he has progressed a lot i think he is
just grabbing some final snack it's
important to hydrate and also
get get those what would you call as a
brain food not bananas what is your
trick robert as a grandmaster what shall
we eat for playing good chess
you know it's funny i don't really eat
during my games and maybe that's why i
haven't increased my rating but uh i
think that's all you know we see maxine
vashila grav nvl always with a platter
of
fruit true platter fruits and nuts have
always been very popular mr bees did
have a few snacks the other day and i
think he he believes in in the ritual it
also helps of course if he has been
having a busy day and he's hungry he's
going for a gambit robert your thoughts
well he goes for this game he loves to
sacrifice material and on the very
second move of the game he plays e4
which harry takes as a free pawn and
after f3 harry is now thinking what to
do he plays knight f6 which is a good
move
defending the e4 square so if the pawn
takes he can take back now mr beast has
moved his knight out to c3 and is
attacking his pawn a second time he
doesn't want to just have even material
he likes the interesting
imbalance of a fight that he uh goes
from these gambits
i wonder if harry will react to this now
the pawn is under the pressure of both
tonight and the pawn shall be listening
with his thought process
okay okay
he's very quiet
and focused on the e pawn he's pushing
e6
mr beast takes the pawn on e4 now he has
a very strong center but harry could
start attacking it if he pins the knight
on c3 and he's about to do so love that
move this should be for developing
creating a concrete threat in the center
of the board so it's a very good start
from harry but mr beast is in his
territory he knows these opening lines
these gambits bishop b4 was a really
good choice as now the e4 pawn is under
attack and black is ready to just castle
next move
uh if you want to
this was a great way um by harry to
react to a gambit that he hasn't studied
he didn't want to hold on to the pawn he
just wanted to get his development quick
he could have even won a pawn if he had
taken the knight and then captured e4 or
the pawn on d4 both central pawns were
in trouble and are still in trouble i
wonder if mr riz will try to hold on to
them now that he has a turn to try to
defend
tough call for him because as you said
the d4 pawn which i wasn't even looking
at at first but then i noticed it while
you're speaking both pawns and center
are vulnerable and that's the danger of
playing these kind of gambits he
regained the material but he hasn't
completed his development the king is in
the center can't castle king's side
because two pieces are in the way so mr
beast needs to be careful right in this
moment otherwise the center will not be
there anymore
yeah difficult decision to take if he if
he finds it accomplished to e5 i think
he will have good chances to get out of
this without losing anything because
that would attack the knight gives him a
momentum
and
right on call e5 wow well played
wow good eye by you anna and mr beast
he's not listening in but i don't think
he's listening uh hello jimmy by the way
in case you are listening
wow and you know he is a philanthropic
guy but he did not want to give his
central pawns and oh look at that move
knight to d5 a good choice by harry but
anna i'm a little nervous because after
that move right there
we could see a minor piece blunder
yes harry needs to realize that the
bishop on b4 is hanging so before he
takes the knight on d5 he should have
captured on d2 with a check let's go
bishop his gun i think we're good i
don't think there's any
witchcraft he could do to screw me over
so he's gotta move his rook
nobody witchcraft has happened what do
we do
there's also this move queen h4 check
which is a very sneaky move uh if harry
had played that because the point of
queen h4 is that your king's in check
and you don't want to move your king so
you block it but when you block the
check in comes the queen to e4 with a
check on not just the king but the rook
in the corner so
that would be an interesting tactic if
harry is allowed
yeah that would have been a beautiful
maybe a way to even turn the tables
fully a kind of variation but very
difficult to see at the same time since
the rook was hanging harry realized that
the rook is attacked so he moved it he
still has i think good chances to punch
back because that queen h4 check is
still in the air and the e5 pin in case
he manages to push f6 and exploit that
the white king is still in the middle of
the board
and it's about time that mr b starts
developing because knight f3 stops the
check on h4 and gets that king one step
closer to being out of the center once
the bishop develops to e2 or to d3 so
another three looks like a very good
move but jimmy's trying to figure it out
let's see well i guess i can see it from
here i was going to say if he's talking
through his thought process sometimes he
does jimmy is not streaming but he does
have his voice also on he hasn't muted
himself on the call just so that we can
hear him but he's super focused right
now and very silent there's no more
banter he knows that this position still
is tricky until he gets his king out of
the way
i have to say this is maybe the quickest
i've seen harry play because he's up
over a min on the clock and usually he's
behind so that's the good news for him
the bad news is he's down to minor piece
down the minor piece but currently
attacking the bishop on b4 to which mr
beast will need to react the meaning
that he's still not castling he's still
a couple of moves away from getting the
king out of danger
and harry as per usual
quite silent you know for a guy who's
not just speaking but freestyle rapping
all the time on his streams and for his
content he's always so quiet when he's
playing chess
i think we have seen these two very
different approaches by pogchamps
participants some of them are obviously
full on content creators and streamers
and they they want to make sure that
they entertain their audience and
sometimes it also helps them with their
thought process that they are thinking
out loud for harry i think is the
opposite he he feels more confident that
he can sit in silence
and think through everything without
having to explain his thoughts
his thoughts are good right now bishop
g4 a very useful move pinning that
knight on f3 because the knight moves
the queen on d1 is lost so that's a very
good move by harry developing attacking
putting pressure in the center the d4
pawn in particular and depending on how
mr beast responds it could actually
get quite questionable for him and he
made the move h3
and just slam everything on his king
and just overload him
that sounds like a plan to me jimmy
that's uh the game plan
true mr b style
all aggressive he wants to push his
pawns forward so we'll see if he makes
move g4 now no he refrains he plays
bishop to a great move but just a moment
ago to
give everybody
an inkling as to why that bar dropped so
much if harry harriet taken on f3 if the
queen takes on f3 it loses sight of the
d4 pawn and once d4 goes down next e5
will fall so unfortunately for harry has
a missed opportunity involving these
central pawns where they would have just
been off the board
it would have given him a lot of
compensation for the piece that is
missing from the board instead he
dropped the bishop back to f5 and mr
beast is offering a trade of bishops
good developing move and he's about to
castle
inside
no not at all
not with this move and especially since
he mentioned he wants to go aggressive
with the attack on the king side i am
certainly thinking that his intention is
castle queenside so that then he can go
all in on the attack well that's a good
idea get his king away from where he
wants to attack and f good move by harry
i know ben feingold wherever he is is
very upset about this move but that pawn
is pinned because the king is still in
the center so f6 threatens to win a pawn
on e5 that's a good choice by harry
i think mr peace was also commenting on
this move but he may
not continue that thought very focused
harry also said a word or two
yeah these players are not the most
talkative of the bunch that we typically
see on these pogchamp streams
and
wow
they're really concentrating deeply here
i like the way harry played that move f6
mr beast playing really well after
securing that piece saw the tactics and
now it's a matter of which direction his
team will go
just
silence from harry
i knew that we are switching here to
listen in he was talking earlier
that's
pretty much the only sound we hear is
when the a move is made
you can hear the pieces go to the
squares uh the chest like calm sounds
and castle queenside indeed by mr beast
going for the opposite side castling
plan and attack on the king's side
and harry's trying to looks like take
that pawn in the center
will he let it go that's always the
question when they're hovering they're
hovering there it is he takes the pawn
good decision by him and if mr beast
isn't careful and allows that pawn one
square forward
that's a baby fork right damn that is a
baby fork i'm up man
yeah he's uh doing fine he just
and he's doing well on the clock that's
the best i think that's the most
important thing right now
for harry
and there's mr beast he's saying
a little something
and then of course he goes back to
silence
i guess i just take it
there
we'll do
[Music]
we'll hit him with uh probably
we'll just do that i'm technically up
two pieces so i don't
mind trading rooks and just trading a
bunch
uh-oh
big mistake there because this pawn
can become
one step further and go with the fork of
the queen and the knight
oh my gosh
the baby fork you mentioned robert
originally mr beast wanted to take the
pawn but then he decided
i could just offer a rook trip so he's
counting on black capturing the pawn on
the e4 and not advancing the pawn that's
what he missed
right because if you take and
well so i was able to grab the piece and
show everybody that is what harry did he
takes rather than pushes and it's
tempting to capture pieces when you can
but it's not always the best thing to do
well that was a missed chance by harry
to win the piece back he captured the
opponent this is what mr beast expected
that's the reason why he played the rook
move to trade
and when you're ahead you want to trade
so it was a good mindset by a beast but
for jimmy needs to be a little bit more
careful because if that pawn had pushed
around the capture he would have
regretted his choice but right now
piece for just one pawn and harry needs
to know when your down material you
don't trade so taking on d4 would not be
good and while he pushes his
pawn it looks like instead you want to
avoid the trades as best you can
it seems he's trying to free his rook or
place the knight on b4 uh the
combination of those thoughts are good
but it gave a chance to mr beast to
trade the knights as well and robert
that's what you said when you're down on
material the simplification of the
position
doesn't help the person with less pieces
the more trades the better it is for mr
beast in this case
yes and harry took with the pawn which
does defend his pun in d5 and that way
the queen isn't stuck defending it but
now he has double pawn so it's kind of a
blessing and a curse at the same time
and mr beast is of a bishop the bishop
is in a weird spot we don't see a bishop
on eighth read very often anna but if he
notes that the bishop hits the f8 square
all the way across the board he can line
up some checkmating attacks by bringing
his rook to the f5
yes i wonder if that's the square he
will be looking at because i'm pretty
sure he wants to get that rook into the
game and
there aren't too many other squares
available rook even would be a big
blunder to attack the queen but that
square is not guarded
yeah i don't see jimmy making a mistake
like that he's playing too well and he's
become too strong of a player but rookie
one tempting because the queen
is in that line but unfortunately the
square is not defended so rook f1
trying to aim for the open f file and
don't forget about that bishop it may be
out of the picture for now but it still
does its part and that can be a deadly
threat
let's see if that's what jimmy will go
for or will he stick to his original
idea of pushing the pawns of the board
there's nothing protecting it there it's
kind of annoying
um
we'll do this
well there he goes great move
man i wish there was less time i wanna i
wish it was more like
grill grueling
you know having to make quick moves
because he might he might with this as
much time as he has be able to think of
something that just like kind of screws
me over
i wonder if that means he doesn't
realize just how good his position is or
if he just has that much respect for
harry because he's up a piece and making
all the best moves and
he's in charge here
he is in charge i think his confidence
has been shaken a little bit by some of
the previous games he was saying he can
only beat london which is not the case
he has been playing really good chess
and even in the matches that he lost he
had chances so i think it's sometimes
that shaken confidence some bad results
can make you believe that even if you're
off material it's not over which no one
should be overconfident but i think
jimmy
should be a bit less concerned he's
playing great chess and for harry it's
so difficult to even find a counter
chance right now he needs to deal with
the threat of rook f8 check which would
win his queen
that's right now the bishop as we've
been mentioning covers the square so the
queen would have to take it and the
bishop would steal that queen off the
board so for harry i could see him
making a move at pawn h6 just to give
his king some space but let's
see what he's thinking here
oh
all right
great choice stepping out of the
background and activating the queen
right it's just a great move right maybe
the best move on the board
and if mr beast wants to
activate further his bishop than that b2
square could become a future target with
a rook on b8
that's a good call and the rook can also
come to e8 line it up with the queen to
create some potential back rank problems
for the king on c1 so
uh with king safety being the most
important thing and mr beast getting us
in time trouble the game certainly is
not over even though i think mr beast
should be able to put this one away
checkmating me
checkmate where is the checkmate we want
to see it jimmy are you looking for
something for you or for your opponent
i think he's worried i'm getting
checkmated
might be the case
although i would love to see a queen to
f3 move lining up the queen and then i
just want to trade queens
oh that
was great
yeah actually and this would threaten
checkmate too so i think he has to trade
yeah i mean i think he has to trade or
is checkmate right
that is correct that is correct with
that
heavy stack on the f5 he was threatening
queen of fate oh well
i'll take it though
i was thinking if i put my rook on f8
but i'm done
just showing that he moved his rookie
checkmate
and harry made space for the king so h6
is a very good move because now the king
can escape to h7 so even if the rook
were not on a8 rook f8 is not checkmate
immediately so good decision there by
harry i'd say
yes great thinking by both players and
mr beast even if the queens are traded
this is something he wanted so as he
said he either will get a queen trade or
he has a checkmate threat so he was
forcing harry to get the queens off of
the board and that's something that he
wants mr beast with the extra piece and
his end game skills robert if you have
been following the games mr beast was
one of the most accurate and impressive
when it comes to end game technique i
even had to ask him like jimmy is it the
dorads cam game manual that ludwig has
never read but owns or do you watch
videos where where does it come from
where does all the technique and skill
come from for end games you just find it
easier when there are less pieces but
it's still
incredibly difficult for a lot of
players
including higher rated players and him
to understand end games to such extent
and play precisely
no you're you're absolutely right i did
see those games and oh there's a big
mistake by harry because c5 can be taken
by the bishop d5 can be taken by the
rook so i understand the inclination you
want to push forward you want to do
something but unfortunately for harry
now this makes jimmy's life much easier
but
your point earlier and i did see those
end games a very good technique by jimmy
he seems to know what to do it's not
going to be perfect but he has the right
mindset when it comes the end game of
bringing the king up like he just did
with king to d2 to start
yes and that's very important to
activate the king in end games it's
something that a lot of beginners would
fail to do since for most of the game
the opening and middle game phase we are
just trying to protect that king hide it
behind the pawns and in the end game
it's quite a contrary it should become a
very active and and attacking piece
that is a key moment i think for that
reason too will jimmy continue i don't
even think i care if he does to be
honest
right the check i'm guessing he's
talking about on that we'll just do this
anyways
you could always see probably the bishop
and then we could have a box box harry
max scenario
oh no poor harry he was doing so well
against box box i know all right all
right i'm getting low on time i think i
i have it in the bag i just need to not
run out of time
it's really mr b's kryptonite is the
clock
and it's at the same time he loves his
bullets so i think he doesn't get that
nervous i was about to say that it's
funny because he's always playing bullet
chess and yet
yeah he's the one down the clock and
gets a little bit rattled when he's down
there and rook f2 great move by harry
don't actually
well mr beast come back with the rook or
just
right
so he takes a pawn harry
now takes the g2 pawn it might become a
pony yes white has the extra bishop
but if rook g3 check is now played anna
then the economy will be taken and
it's a true race
and that's what mr beast is expecting so
he he saw that by
allowing the capture of of his g2 pawn
this is coming that both both players
will be capturing all paul's possible
and start running with the past pawns
and you know it's funny you almost don't
want that bishop on a3 because it's
blocking your pawns path you want to
just push the pawn a4 and move the ropes
probably shouldn't have blocked my
bishop and that was dumb but luckily i
have a big lead so
i think i'm good
oh
oh that rook trade is not exactly what
harry was supposed to do
no that made
life much easier for mr beast and he
quickly retreats the king he'll move his
bishop he'd mention how
his king will previously block the
bishop and then his apon will just
scurry up the board and net him the full
point
and he's moving in the right direction
just in case the black king makes it to
the h3 pawn he's going toward the only
chance of black the kingside pawns
so he's doing the right thing he can't
even bring his king to g4 stop the pawns
in their tracks and eventually bring the
bishop in to help him win pawns and yeah
this is
as long as even primo
partially causing a bit of a heart
attack but now he captures the pawn
that was stupid ah
all right what are we doing what are we
doing
you know anna there's a strange
possibility of stalemate if
uh mr b just pushes the h-bond at the
board with the king
and you get stalemate in the corner if
you're not careful but yeah he's
probably not gonna make that mistake
well we shall see he's moving the bishop
away so that harry's pawn can move
and will he then start pushing the h
pawn or the queen side pawns he has
plenty of good moves here thankfully
it's one of those ones where i get extra
time every move so i'm not really in a
rush
he probably could trap my bishop somehow
i don't know
all right i'll push the pawn
be free
uh okay we'll just take his pawn
he gave emotional support to that i just
someone just tell them to move quick so
we don't have to drag this one out
what's impressive is not just that mr
biss finds these moves obviously he's up
a piece so there are a couple of ways in
which white can win but
the confidence with which he's so sure
that you just use that h-pass pawn as a
magnet you draw the opponent's king
toward that pawn and then you win on the
other flank you don't need to promote
that h-pawn
that's absolutely right as a decoy and
as your magnet the king one grabbed it
now look at all these three past pawns
and the bishop
should be
an easy finish here for mr beast
but as you said robert it could still be
still made if there's a misstep it could
be i mean look at this if
the king goes into the corner and a8 and
then pawn goes to c6
that would be stalemate
and harry is heading toward the corner
he goes to the corner that would just be
a brilliant try
uh that's unfortunately the wrong way
should have went to a8
you chose the more active move but
unfortunately activity doesn't help for
stalemate
but if king goes to a6 and the king goes
to b4 but he's not mr b is not going to
do that that would also be a stalemate
it's true that this is a potential
stalemate if the king moves what
will it be
resign
tell me chess.com tell me
are we supposed to play this out to the
bitter end
he actually has a chance here
because if he brings the king to c8 in
front of the pawn the white king can't
go to c6
indeed it could still be stalemate king
c8 king c6 is still made
will mr beast do it or does he see that
he shouldn't
play it
oh my gosh
you know he employed the strategy of
boring me to death and then give me a
still mate and he got it i honestly did
not feel like thinking amazing anymore i
was kind of amazing these long terms
that never resemble just 500 moves
i wish there was a way you could just
like subtract time and make them faster
wow
well it worked out this is what we were
talking about the last chance of harry
and he got it
i i can't believe it he brought the king
in front of the pawn mr beast was doing
all of the right things but as he said
it himself i wish that it weren't
dragged out so much that we just had a
rush because he probably would have won
under those circumstances i am in
disbelief anna
this was a game that was dominated by mr
beast and yet harry's
resilience and continuing the game even
though he felt like he should have
resigned it paid odds it it managed to
get him half a point meaning that we are
going into the second game
with a match that is tied
wow well we are going to take a quick
break and when returned we'll get to the
second half of this match between mr
beast and harry mack
think about moves
noted noted
oh man
oh the chess.com analysis was wild in
real time what were they saying
next time try to win yes for sure for
sure epic draw
you did great now you're warmed up
appreciate it appreciate it yes very
excited
my hairy thank you i understand you're
quite a
a chess master yourself
you got to think about what the opponent
will do sometimes yes i am trying to do
that believe it or not it might not look
like it but yes i am i am attempting to
uh to anticipate what the opponent might
do
shout out to apple slices
we got the stalemate play
mr b said you used the method to bore
him to death at the end
yeah by that
okay
oh i'm on chess.com we here we here
chess.com hmac i'm coming through to
bless this song y'all know i spit the
lyrics that are raw i bored mr beast to
death and got the draw for real
oops what happened to my chat
commercial at the moment
that was epic
wow can't believe i'm playing somebody
so so famous this is incredible
mental health is a serious topic and i'm
here to tell you that it's absolutely
okay to talk about it many people over
the course of their life will struggle
with something for me personally it's
always been different types of anxieties
and i know that i can be kind of prone
to bottling it all up i don't feel like
i want to bother those around me with it
so i just try to overcome it by myself
but i have found that it's better to
confide in my loved ones or my friends
or
in therapy but one of the major barriers
to therapy is the cost and so today we
are raising money for rise above the
disorder or rad for a hundred thousand
therapy sessions just a thirty dollar
donation will support therapy for one
week so do me a favor
reach out
talk to somebody you're not alone in
this we're all going through this
together and we can overcome
mental health access and affordability
near and dear to our hearts we want to
thank god from chess levy for that
statement and appreciate all the
generous support we've had thus far in
game one of this consolation bracket
match between harry mack and mr beast it
was a miraculous stalemate the freestyle
rapper survives mr beast living up to
his reputation as being incredibly
charitable because he
allowed harry to end that game with a
half point
indeed we were talking about the
excellent endgame skills of mr beast and
it was true all the way until he was
this close to conversion but as he
himself said he was bored he wanted to
just finish the game
and harry kept going kept playing and
earned that still mate so it's half a
point for both players
and we are in game two here d4 by harry
d5 but mr beast harry on the clock and
well he's trying to figure out where to
move which is a little disconcerting
he can't deny it
tell us about that prep tell us about
those screen captures robert oh you know
i sent him a bunch of screen captures
and it seems that he's trying to
remember what to do and that's what
happens with newer players like
memorizing openings is not
a typical thing it's not like he's been
playing much chess is his first month of
chess um but he was trying to contain
the beast because mr beast loves to
sacrifice material i just want to give
him a solid opening
this is very solid indeed and i'm
wondering if harry will follow up with a
bishop development or push his e pawn to
get the f1 bishop out
i won't give away anything but i really
hope he leads with his bishop first
before pushing that ethon i see it
smells like london
yeah well
i'm personally in new york but yes the
london
is choosing between the f4 and g5
squares it seems
yes he choose knight c3 which is a
perfectly fine move
he's just trying to figure it out
and then just pure silence
i wonder if mr beast will find a way to
spice things up or will he go for just a
more solid approach please bishop to f5
good developing move
yeah so far great play by mr beast
and that reminded harry of a very same
pattern moving the bishop out to f4 if
he ends up choosing that square and he's
about to drop it there it goes he drops
an f4 so it's a london system and of
course mr b is directly going for an
attack and this is something that's not
easy to spot if you're new this you
might play a3 get that knight out of
there but then you'd be welcoming the
knight to the c2 square so uh hopefully
harry
has his eyes in that pawn and critical
moment
shall we check in with his stream he
already chose a move though i was
wondering which
pawn or piece he was gonna click on he
chooses e4 interesting way to block the
bishop
that's a mr b style move right like a
pawn sacrifice in the center just mixing
up the state of affairs here and i think
that's going to cause mr beast to settle
in for a thing
super focused by harry and the creative
move upon sacrifice that this palm bush
will mistake it with a palmer with the
bishop
it's one of these moments where because
mr beast is a sacrificial player plays
similar things from the uh white side it
can be hard to play against it from the
black side but he takes for the pawn
which is great and uh-oh bishop b5 check
i understand the impulse banana
that is a move with repercussions here
let's see how mr b sphere reacts to that
check i'm guessing palm push because
that would chase the bishop back and at
the same time the knight is still
hanging so two minor pieces will be in
the air
if jimmy finds that pump push
yes and
seems like he's thinking trying to
figure it out
yeah i guess we just do that
very good move so he's probably gonna
bring his knight up to e5
right or
i'm confused so i got two of his pieces
in my crosshairs
he's just taken away
and unfortunately for harry it's also
still that night fork on c2 not just the
knight that has been i still have the
the fork with the knight
indeed
so i think i just hit him with it
he probably won't take with this queen
no he won't so
i'll just take his knight
or sorry rook
i think what i see on harry's stream
that is that he is trying to castle out
of the check it would be great if it was
allowed
yeah it's one of those things where i
i'm actually not sure we went over that
uh when we started
he was really brand new to chess like a
complete beginner knew how the pieces
moved
and that was it so i'm not sure we went
over you can't castle when you're in
check
yeah he tried but in the end he goes for
what he didn't want to go for when he
was freestyling about the bunk club a
delayed bomb cloud it is
yeah so now mr beats the head on the
clock and
huge advantage on the board upper rook
white's king in the center
and
no stalemates this time right anna
no stalemates and he can capture even
more material if he takes on d4
and he sees it both bishops are hanging
now
let's check back with mr beast and kids
looking at his thoughts too
i feel kind of bad
unless he somehow just like
takes my queen then
and take it back
what is it that he feels bad about
winning chess games
it seems he feels bad about dominating
the match but he didn't feel that bad
about
harry getting the stalemate he was upset
does he
i don't actually think there's a way he
can guard both his bishops
right he's correct
i don't see an attack on my king
i think he's just very unfortunate for
him
um
i think we just take this
uh well it seems like mr beast is
spawning all the tactics he saw both
bishops were hanging but i like that he
double checked instead of just
immediately capturing the bishop 104
he's like is there something against my
king is there some tactic here he
realized there wasn't off goes the
bishop
yeah and he's feeling sorry for harry
because it literally is that after that
knight was lost on f3 everything just
fell apart one after the other more and
more pieces were captured so in that
sense it really is unfortunate that
harry missed that moment when he gave a
check with the bishop and two of his
minor pieces were hanging and ever since
mr beast kept capturing one piece after
the other full-on force he just needs to
bring out the rest of his pieces because
he was really good at capturing
everything that was there to pick up but
that king's side still needs to be
developed
that's right and if harry makes him like
knight b5 at some point do not take that
piece right he's taking enough pieces
but that's the thing you know the king
in the center you could get checkmated
if you're not careful because
all of these pieces bishop the knight
and the rook have not activated
themselves yet so knight f6 to start
with seems to be the best way and then
harry will have to resort to tricks
that's a very good point that knight b5
would be a poisonous move and that
knight should not be taken if the king
is still there on e8 but i wonder if
jimmy will now go for the knight jump
or
maybe a pawn push to try to get the f8
bishop out but he certainly needs
developing moves now
that's right
it could be tempting to make him like
pawn to b5 to attack the bishop but that
walks in to the problems and that's a
pretty good move to d8
simplifying the position he has been
religiously sticking to let's simplify
if i'm ahead on material and he likes
his own games too so i think in both
senses
it it is what has been working very well
for him
right and
rookie one look at harry saying i'm down
material i shouldn't trade
but there's an impending checkmate if mr
beast can find damn man
not many prospects here my friends
i'm down a lot of material
has it ever been done i don't know
okay yeah yeah yeah okay
what a move by mr b setting up the mate
not letting the king go to f1 um
so rook d2 or queen d2 both would be
checkmate
will harry see it
i like the new thing on knight b5
now it's up to mr beast will we find it
there it is
damn
there you have it my friends
weak
worst game i played in the whole thing
man
worst game i've played in the whole
thing
oh
shout out to mr beast though damn
well y'all i'm sorry
the player's name should not be sorry
though he he played really well way
above his level but mr beast has been
dominating this match and this could be
the play of the game what do you think
robert our eternal play of the game
choice
oh it has to be this game of course game
one and stalemate but if we scroll back
a bit as they play the game presented by
eternal.gg i think it came when harry
went bishop f4 knight to b4 it just
rattled harry because he's not used to
this opening it was the first time he
played d4 and it's a really big threat
here on c2 so e4 sort of evidences that
harry saw the threat but rook to c1 aka
move not easy to play if you're new to
the position so and after e4 it seemed
like mr b's just took everything he
could find
he did he took one piece after the other
i certainly agree with you that after
night before it was all in mr b's hand
to to cash in and convert this match he
is moving on to the semi-finals and if
you agree with us or not make sure to
let us know you need to just connect
your twitch account on eternal.gigi and
type eternal in the chat every time you
believe that that's a moment to
eternalize we're gonna choose three
lucky winners per match so make sure to
use eternal in the chat as many times as
you think
that is a clippable
eternalizable moment in your opinion and
you can win some of the
book champs special edition packs also
it's possible to buy them but you need
to be quick because they are running low
on stock there's only 3 000 available
that was the original number i think we
are down to 10 and it all goes for
charity all the proceeds
well people can collect them as they
wish they should sign up with eternal.gg
but for now we have to say gg to harry
back bring him and mr beast on for an
interview and we're back in a few to
hear their thoughts
[Music]
and we return with both mr beast and
harry mack
jimmy congrats that was another great
performance even if the first game
didn't end the way you wanted it to
thank you i appreciate it you know we
were talking before we went live and now
we gotta repeat everything we just
talked about five seconds ago
the director whatever came in he's like
guys shut up wait till you're alive to
talk about this
it was funny uh but yeah no it was it
was good i was telling them that like i
just kind of gotten alone where i was
like yeah i got like five extra pieces
i'll just move them and it'll work
itself out and then the stalemate popped
up and i was like well
probably why you shouldn't do that
harry how did it feel when you suddenly
saw on your screen that you saved the
game
you know what to be honest i was i was
as surprised as anybody i think uh i was
i was just moving my pieces around on my
stream i was asking like yo am i
supposed to resign like is that what's
supposed to happen i was like chess.com
let me know if i'm just wasting
everybody's time right now so uh yeah
that was cool man i was i was surprised
and happy that uh i didn't take the l
there
no you did not you saved a half point
you can't save games that you resigned
so it's good to keep fighting when you
can and jimmy on your end uh you're
moving on in the consolation bracket how
are you feeling you did start the
tournament off with a bang with mr beast
immortal by beating ludwig how are you
feeling are you feeling ready to take
down this bracket yeah um who's next who
do i play next
i believe you're playing tekton next and
he's got a great pokemon shirt prepare
for that okay
uh
is what's his rating
about five six
yeah
i was gonna say you should be the
favorite but he does love his hippo i
can tell you that he plays the
hippopotamus religiously with both
colors you need to look up that opening
if you're listening hello
yeah no i'm excited it'll be fun and
yeah that's all around this is i was
telling him also off camera like when
so i last pog champs i just literally i
think i only won like one out of ten
games or something stupid like that and
so it's kind of just like tradition you
just like you lose a bunch of first time
and then you play and then the next time
you win a few and then i'm hoping next
time i can win even more and we just
keep adding a better win rate each fog
champs
yeah it's true it does need some
experience to play here ludwig is here
for the third time and yet you almost
took him down
exactly
yeah harry how are you feeling about the
chess i mean i know the results haven't
gone your way and you and i have talked
but how you feeling after uh the
elimination here you know what man uh
honestly i'm i'm excited to uh continue
on my chess journey like i actually like
chess you know and i didn't know that
that was gonna be the case like i signed
up for this because i've always wanted
to learn
and uh and so you know i was kind of
like thrown right into the ring and uh
you know even though i didn't win any
games uh it's been dope man and i'm
excited to continue playing so maybe
maybe uh if i'm lucky enough to be
invited back to the next pog champs i
can show some uh some true great now
everyone next hug champs will
underestimate you and then you just slap
them right that's what i'm going for
that's what i'm going set some low
expectations yeah this is all long game
man i'm thinking many more be hilarious
if it really was long dave
uh before we send you both off can we do
something fun harry if you're cool with
it can each of us give you one word and
we'll do an amigo bar style freestyle
rep
with that oh of course i'm good you
already know let me get a beat ready
here
i got my word first you got your word
yeah vos
i'm ready here we go
oh so i got to be ready okay what are
the words what are the words sorry i
missed it what was it jimmy voss
vos
yep
does it need to be one bird or kenny to
be too so it's gonna be like a compound
hyphenated word situation you know
i'm gonna go with stalemate still
the immortal stalemate yes very relevant
i'm gonna go with epiphany epiphany boss
stalemate
and epiphany we ready we didn't give you
much to work with good luck i'm gonna
pop outside watch it on the stream
come on hey come on hey come on listen
listen every time i freestyle i'm a
lyrical boss hey all these rappers
fragile just like a boss listen when i
do my thing i'm putting rhymes in your
face hold up is it sad boss or is it
pronounced bass h-mag when i'm on it man
i'm holding it down and king in this
thing i'm about to get the gold in this
crown i make it happen and y'all know
rap is increasing the fail rate can't
believe i saved the game clutching the
stalemate hey yo mac imma make it happen
properly known for putting all of these
words together logically hey yo y'all
know that every rap is the joint i saved
the day i came through and got half a
point yeah and y'all know that each year
we gonna improve i'm playing the long
game first part champs i lose next time
around i'll be underestimated then i'm
about to slap them and they couldn't
test the greatness can't get rid of me i
spit the free exquisitely they having
brilliant ideas i'm spitting them
epiphanies man got the top of the dome
every time i freestyle i'm part champs
i'm a lock in the zone yeah we gonna
make it happen i'm coming for the award
first time i played chess what's for
park champs four yeah yo hash you a good
coach i can't front you got me up to
speed for only playing chess for one
month yeah we still in it my bars they
infinite when it comes to kicking revs
man i never been timid i told you we've
been having them epiphanies and it's an
honor to have played against mr beast
let's go
oh my gosh
absolutely epic thank you so much harry
you have gained so many fans in the
chess community and your opponents too
have become your fans i have seen each
and every one of them tuning into your
streams ever since they played against
you oh that's incredible that's
incredible well no man it's it's an
absolute honor to uh to be a part of
this competition i'm gonna up my chess
game for next year so i'm coming for
y'all let's go see you at just five
i'm gonna continue watching your
freestyles in the meantime this has been
a blast appreciate it thank you guys
take care man yes sir
wow
absolutely epic and what's also epic is
that each and every one of you can get
five dollars in bitcoin for free that is
thanks to our sponsor coinbase
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase and
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or if you are
already an experienced trader coinbase
is the place to go to all you need to do
is register and verify that you are an
actual human being and you get your five
dollars in bitcoin to start with that is
an excellent opportunity to get
acquainted with cryptocurrency
yes indeed it's a good thing to do and
well we are going to have to go on a
short break because when we return we'll
have the third match for the day between
i am christine and fundy in the
championship bracket you will not want
to miss that match
[Music]
so
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered earn crypto by learning about
crypto with coinbase earn power up your
trading with coinbase's advanced
features get exclusive rewards when you
spend with coinbase card and much more
learn more at coinbase.com
chess
and we return ready for this matchup
between fundy and chris and anna you've
worked with chris is she ready for fundy
as the
top rated player the player that all the
other competitors think is the favorite
i think she's ready it's true that fondy
we consider him as one of the favorites
for winning the overall tournament and
chris has only been studying chess for a
month but she is the player as you
highlighted robert who has improved the
most she has done an incredible progress
starting from just what you said knowing
how the pieces move and with every
single coaching session and with every
single match in her group stage she kept
becoming a more and more formidable
player to such an extent that
she knocked out rubios of the
championship bracket that was the last
match of the group stage and we have an
e4 start already i don't have more time
for in showing this match let's see how
the opening will turn out e45
well so far normal but let's see what
chris is thinking because she's on the
black
[Music]
what do you want here what is that
bishop move forward so she's already
looking at the f7 square
she's saying she couldn't develop her
bishop too and castle very good thinking
chris
a few things with the captures but then
the end goes for bishop c5 and she's
saying that she wants to castle because
she is one of those players in pogchamps
that
you you hear the exact same thought
process that we teach but it's not so
easy to apply what we teach when your
opponent makes them all question what
what is the idea of that move are they
threatening something do do i need to
react to that threat if it's a real
threat and it's something that we try
really hard as coaches to make our
students understand how important it can
be for a game but it's extremely
difficult to do it at every turn yet she
does it i'm very impressed how she
always always sticks to that thought
process
and we saw that moment with the bishop
pointing at the f7 square she was what
does fundy want how can i deal with it
if you just scroll back quickly the
point was after bishop c5 if knight g5
was played to gang up on that pawn on f7
she realized she could castle and if
knight takes f7 rook takes bishop takes
king takes this is a known
imbalance here where black gets two
minor pieces for rook and palm but it's
very good for black as you can see on
the evaluation bar because though the
king is out not enough white pieces to
attack that king and then black will
have the extra material so uh that
didn't happen of course fundy too strong
to go for that his rating nearly 1300
he is improving during the tournament
we're just not even noticing because he
was already one of the favorites
he was already 1200 rated approximately
1200 or just below 1200 and now as we
can see gaining rating and it's always
christmas for funding we have learned
about that too
yeah i want to hear him speak some dutch
because if chris is going to be speaking
in spanish and i don't speak spanish i
also want to hear some dutch because i
don't get that either
i'm hoping i don't need to translate
that because i have no clue what but 95
now chris is analyzing the calculator
i don't want him to come to this square
she's pointing at c7 in case in the
future that will be captured
so she's trying to simplify the position
and get rid of that dangerous knife
now she's thinking of bishop e6 she's
considering whether bishop g4 or bishop
e6 is a better development and both of
them make a lot of sense
she's saying that white only has in
reality one active piece the d5 bishop
and everything else she's ahead in in
development she's right
don't understand the words but her arrow
and where she bring in the mouse i see
and she's doing everything correctly
like really just a great move bishop g4
and on fundy's end c3 is a great
decision because this knight wanted to
jump into d4 you want to put pressure on
a pinned piece but now the pawn on c3
covers that square so good decisions by
both thus far
it's extremely important as you said
that palm push and fondy played it so
quickly that also shows his level that
he he spots these moves and understands
the importance of those modes
immediately let's check in with his
stream and what he's saying
yeah we can hear what fundy's thoughts
are because
uh he's got the white sun he wants
something
i just moved back with my
bishop right
now i just moved back
or i can go to a6 but then my bishop
becomes kind of useless there but then i
can rotate it back to c4
do i want to lose a bishop just randomly
for a night
so i can go d5
if they take with the knight i take with
the pawn stack pawns but i'm up
um
i can go a6
a6 allows
b6 with eric um rook but that allows me
to go back to c4 attacking again
they push bomb i take they take i take
they take
i don't know
i think i want to save my bishop
actually a pretty big choice anna
because bishop a6 is funny which is
saying saves the bishop but after that
move black can play f5
striking as now white's pieces are sort
of off to the side on the queen side
trying to open the f file use this pin
on the knight and f3 and go for an
attack so it's a big choice by fundy and
he didn't play bishop a6 after all he
decided to play bishop retreats to d5
which is the safer move to allow the
trade of his bishop for the knight on e7
but at the same time as he said he is up
a pawn even if those pawns will be
doubled on the d
and i think
chris she can play f5 anyway try to play
e4 and work this pin because it may cost
you some material but white's king side
will be completely compromised if you're
able to force white to take with the
pawn on f3 so f5 an aggressive move is
this a type of move that chris can play
because oftentimes newer players they
refrain from pushing their kingside
pawns
i want to check in with her stream
because i think she's about to find it
and i was gonna tell you robert that if
she doesn't find it it's on me because i
told her that the f pawn should stay on
the board where it is glued to the board
because of your kingdom
she's saying exactly that i know that i
shouldn't push that poem for the safety
of my king but i want to advance in the
center she was looking at e4 earlier and
even though i taught her that for the
king safety that f phone better stay
very normally is she overruled the rule
that's that's when you know that the
player is capable of more than the
rating that that's shown on the screen
that she understands that she can
possibly jump that rule here this is an
exception
wow i'm extremely impressed
she's calculating e4 to capitalize
wow this is an extremely strong move and
i was going to tell you robert then my
prediction would have been that because
i told her not to touch the f-bomb she
wouldn't do it but i'm so happy that she
was like i know this is normally bad for
my king but i want to do it
i'm so impressed
i just seen her games
throughout when i was on vacation and
pogchamps is underway
she's really doing
so well and and it's great to see
because this is kind of what pogchamps
is all about players who may not even
know that they enjoy chess until they
start trying and her writing is 509
you've got to be kidding me 509s don't
play like this she has a great
understanding she's figuring it out on
the fly you've done some great coaching
as well but as i always say you know
when i'm working with someone their
successes are because of them they're
failures i take the fault for but right
now exactly in great shape i'm serious i
was gonna take the phone for if there's
no f5 push it's me because i taught her
not to do it
and i think funny's a bit nervous he
plays d4 because he wants to get rid of
the spot and look at that
she's so quickly instead of taking this
pawn on d4 which removes her previous
threat of pawn to e4 and you see the
evaluation part go up for white she says
let me just retreat my bishop to b6
because the knight is still pinned so in
the event a pawn takes pawn pawn takes
pawn well there's no knight takes pawn
for you you lose your queen and now e4
is coming whether you like it or not
this is fantastic play thus far from
chris
i am very impressed and also of course i
know i'm super biased but the fact that
only a few weeks ago one of one of the
lessons we had was about pins because
she didn't know what to pin so she had
one lesson on it and she's applying it
to such extent that she
she's a natural and she's really good at
strategic games
she she said that to her chest is just
like
playing jungle in league of legends i
don't
see how that is so
much the same for her but she has always
loved strategic games and just thinking
through a plan and carrying it out
and
she's doing a great job and it looks
like the move rook oh
one second let me
refresh no it goes capture so i think i
need to
hard refresh here my analysis uh change
things up
she is hovering over the e5 which is
she's saying you can't do anything to me
and i am i am threatening your night
[Music]
she's saying that she would be up
material in that case i wonder though
how she'll react to bishop g5 because
that's a good attempt by fondy to mess
things up now that the queen on d8 is
hanging
and
it's getting a bit tighter she can just
move her queen out the way and say that
knight remains pinned so move like say
queen d7 would be tempting but the
knight just because it's pinned doesn't
mean it can't move so queen d7
all of a sudden this knight can hop to
e5 where you take white's queen
white takes black screen with a fork so
you have to be careful in these moments
because a pin unless there's a king
behind it does not mean that the piece
is unable to move
yeah this is a difficult choice and also
just simply capturing on g5 would mean
that uh you are giving up your queen for
the bishop the knight can take it and
then you take white's queen as well but
it is only a trade in a position where
black was trying to win a piece and at
the end of this white would be up a pawn
so that would be really good news for
fundy so it's a critical moment right
now as chris tries to figure out where
the queen goes she can play bishop takes
f3 not the easiest move to make when
your own queen is under attack but you
take the knight which removes the guard
of this bishop and after the bishop
takes queen bishop takes queen we have
the same scenario for both sides where
the bishops are hanging but black is up
a bishop so it's a forcing sequence if
she's able to find it but she's on the
clock and it's not that easy to work
through those complications
let's see where she drawing those arrows
are pointing with the mouse
she does like to play end game she does
like to to get the queens off of the
board but i'm hoping she will think a
bit more about it in case she finds the
other capture
okay
i'm not gonna sell it in the end i'm not
gonna sell my queen in the end
she doesn't want to just go for the
trade yet i think she likes to keep the
the threat there and that's the right
thought um or seeing obviously that
bishop takes f3 which was which was
gonna be winning a piece the only
downside of placing the queen on eight
that now that e for pawn is pinned as
well so both queens are in a pin
that's right although the good thing
about queen eight is making use of the
fact that pawn is no longer an f7
because the queen can jump over to g6
and help with an attack so if this queen
thinks it's just leaving the pin and all
is good like queen the
c2 for example i can't take enough three
with the pawn and who's my queen but if
i take the bishop
the pawn has to take and in comes that
queen with a pin and a win of a piece so
queen eight does have its merits here i
actually like the move i think it's very
practical and for somebody who doesn't
move their f-pawn ever because she was
taught you shouldn't do it most of the
time that was good coaching honestly
that now she realizes hey maybe wait is
this no
no
oh no
she forgot about the queen
oh just when she had it that queen city
would have
that was happened unfortunate but she's
still in the game in fact because she
took a piece under the queen
[Music]
okay okay
okay
no problem
i hope that she will bounce back because
it's so difficult once you make a
mistake of that that kind to to still
believe that you have chances and she
does with the pair of bishops the rook
could come to e2 there's attack against
the white king the white king quite a
strong attack there
yeah actually
rookie two looks like a great move
because rook wow there's some very
beautiful tactics at play here where if
you go rookie 2 you want to defend this
f2 pawn and rook f1 is the way to do so
but after pawn takes g2 king g2 look at
this move anna bishop e3 just like i
love the
way this looks because the f pawn is
pinned and can't take the bishop the
bishop shouldn't take because the queen
is hanging now i don't think i've ever
seen a tactic like this but it is
gorgeous
it would be incredible if it happened
i'm afraid that chris has come for a
different move placing the bishop on g6
i think she lost the thread there a
little bit and
it's just very difficult to recover from
moments of blunder but i'm hoping that
she will realize that it's not over
wow i mean bishop g6 is still a
reasonable move because i think fundy
will struggle to play move like pawn
takes f3 and even then she can still
play rook
that move was not good because f4 anna
the queen would be under
she found it so quickly she played it
immediately that's why she plays the
bishop on g6 she already had that move
on her mind and g3 made it even better
for her
oh my gosh just pawn takes g3 there's a
pin on the diagonal and fundy's king
just because there's no black queen on
the board does not mean that there's no
attack this king side is in shambles and
she might just go ahead and checkmate
the king
let's check in with kristen if she plays
it i was going to say but she already
took the pawn on g3 i think now
we need to check into this
soon if he's all right
wait wait wait wait wait i'm gonna take
one of two i'm not
too but she's saying i can't go there
yet until i'm not doubled on the e file
she's sensing that there's quite some
attack here for her even if she doesn't
know exactly
she really wants to get the rookie one
move in but she needs to she needs to
prepare it a bit more
i'd love to listen with fondy if he's
talking about uh his thoughts um because
this game is turning upside down yikes
checkmate one if she sees it
will she see it and does fondy see it
let's go back to chris i would like to
see those arrows is she pointing at this
bad
i need that bishop on b6 gone somehow
i don't think fondly realizes that he
could be he could get checkmate right
now with bishop to d3
will chris see it
i think she's really focused on the
rookie one move that's where she's
pointing on her stream
oh funny sees it
yeah he definitely sees it right now
uh-oh
i should have gone to h
a hundred percent
just don't do it
will that work robert he's hurting
himself oh you gotta almost feel bad for
them
chris is saying i'm gonna go for the
aggressive move she doesn't support the
maid but she does put another aggressive
move
the bishop and i'm defending my pawn
she's saying her position is still great
yes
unless fondi is offering her to take
what he has just played rookie one ps2 i
think i know why he did that he saw the
checkmate ideas and he just trying to
like escape even if it cost him a lot of
material
he played rook to even offering the rook
it really must be what you're saying
robert that he wants to get some love
for that king it needs to breathe
she has the same checkmate though rook
takes and bishop d3 results in the same
checkmate we're just looking at it's
very hard to take with the rook anyone
when you can take with a pawn but this
move bishop to d3 as well will lead to
checkmate as long as she realizes that
bishop can come into the picture
i think she's trying to bring in her
other rook and she has just double rooks
on the e5 to maintain the pressure and
put more wood on fire
it's actually kind of a great
and now she's saying that i think this
rook move was good to double rooks and
uh maintain the pressure there and did
she see that she could take that oh my
gosh that rook on e1 with the pawn but
now it's just take with the pawn
i i know you had the
oh
oh she took with the rook do you think
she's just so focused on maintaining the
rook on e2 that she didn't even consider
that capturing with the pawn would have
led to promoting that pawn next move i
was completely winning on the spot both
pawns are there on the second rank
and checkmate soon
and now her king is up and
she
showed the king up and do you see the
eval bar it's going up in white's favor
and then back i don't even know why it
went up in white's favor
this is such a complex game i think
it's very normal that the players are
missing a move here and there um it's
not a normal structure to have the
doubled pawns so close to the white king
it must be very confusing to both
players
oh my gosh it's checkmate one
oh my gosh you will finally see it chris
had made him one earlier we'll find the
sheet now
what
oh crystal's still just looking wait why
is it mate where is the check she is
very confused because obviously she was
focusing on her own attack i don't think
she realized that her king too can get
into this much trouble it came out of
the blue
and fundy
for him christmas came early because
that was a true gift he was all sorts of
busted and yet he escapes not even just
with surviving but with a full point it
takes a one nothing lead and i i really
can't believe what just happened there
but that's what time trouble does to you
that's what time trouble does but there
will be a second game we're gonna take a
quick break and then maybe there will be
a tiebreaker if chris continues like
this because honestly even though fundy
is the higher rated player and favorite
for the overall championship this was a
very exciting game where black had
chances chris had checkmate in one
yeah it wasn't even just chances she was
pretty much winning throughout she was
playing so well unfortunately go her way
this has happened time and time again in
chess events but for now we are gonna
head to a quick break and we return
we'll be back with the second game of
this match from fundy and i am christine
[Music]
so
we know everyone loves some good
old-fashioned merch there's new merch
available go to go.chess.com
merch and get 15 off with the code pog 4
and you notice that best seller in the
middle danny can only hate on it so much
it continues to sell anna i think at
this point i also need to get one even
though i don't really want one
i think danny is selling it by
completely disagreeing with the choice
of the community making it a bestseller
when he hates it i love the pattern i
love the colors make sure to pick up any
of the merch items with 15 off by using
the code block four
indeed and well now game two is underway
chris gets the white pieces she starts
with e4 we get a sicilian anna have you
done any work on swim with chris because
it may not be a familiar opening to new
players
i have made a video preparing against
fonday's openings i don't know how much
of that will come across because
all these days chris has been extremely
busy and it's very difficult as you know
when the creator's schedule doesn't
allow much coaching so i tried my best
to sum up everything in a five minute
video and let's see how much of that
will be on the board i do like the
knight development and if she remembers
to push the pawn to d4
and we have her on screen
she doesn't understand fully these palm
pushes that are the bishop pawn she is
not that familiar with these openings
but she already improved from what she
played against crockett's because there
she moved bishop to b5 on on the second
move against the sicilian that's how
confused she was about this pawn push
and we'll see if she plays your d4
suggestion
[Music]
anything to my queen because your queen
is blocked good thinking
she's still upset due to the first game
so she's saying let's make this a quick
game but i'm hoping quick game in a
sense that she is upset i'm gonna go
super aggressive she likes to attack
did she analyze the first game does she
knows she missed the checkmate
yeah yeah she was analyzing it during
the whole break and she realized that
she had checkmate and that she should
have taken only two with the pawn so
she's really upset that she missed it
off to a
very fine start thus far in fact fundy
moved the same pawn twice and oh this is
a good teaching moment very good
teaching moment so fundy moved the same
pawn two times in the opening e6 and
then e5 and in the process chris just
made a great move because the d6 square
is loose as only the bishop defends and
the queen will recapture so knight d6
check is a way to get the bishop pair
and control the dark scores if black
says no d6 for you put a6 but then
knight comes into d5 and all of a sudden
black is toast because the c7 square so
moving the same piece twice in the
opening these pawns like this it could
be a big problem
it could be a big problem and i'm
wondering if fund is looking at those
options now after a6
chris is sort of forced into knight b6
she doesn't want to play knight back to
a3 so then you look at your other
options and knight d6 stands out
she's looking at the square on her
stream i think she's just double
checking if there's anything else can i
just like be very annoying
somehow
great decision
oh okay
that's fair
i think fundy was surprised by that
[Music]
let's see if he'll find a way to deal
with that queen on d6 it's a beast and
knight to d5 screen d
like queen e7 is that good they'll go
queen
c7 maybe
i can draw the arrows for him i think
this is okay
he wants to offer the queen trade and he
does if they go queen c7 right
um i can push my pawn to d6 and i think
that traps the queen unless
okay well
i guess we just do that don't say that
chris really loves trading queens so i
was i was guessing that she would be
happy with the trade on e7
she
very much should be because she has the
bishop pair and this pawn is called the
backwards pawn so when white either goes
rook d1 or castles regardless there will
be a rook on this file staring at this
pawn she's
really playing excellent chest thus far
immediately brings the bishop back and
uh i think one of her best
characteristics of chess player is
keeping the tension alive rather than
forcing trades because a lot of people
would see i can take a knight let me do
that she says no my bishop is good and
what are you going to do about it if you
play g5 my bishop safely runs back to g3
and attacks this pawn i mean seriously
she is playing great chess in these two
games thus far
yes i'm very impressed and that she
doesn't let the opponent get an easy
development by trading on e7 we would
only be helping the black pieces to get
out that g8 knight is still undeveloped
as well as the rest of the king side and
the c8 bishop basically black needs to
hurry up but funding goes for another
knight move with the same piece chasing
the bishop
and now there's a cool choice you can
play knight d5 the knight moved away
from e7 that threatens a big fork on the
c7 square we mentioned the dark square
problems for black all these pawns are
in light squares you see these pawns
which means that square is like
let me change the color in that b6 d6 c7
c5 all these light squares are under
white's control so and eventually knight
to d5 would be good but she protects her
bishop
ruins her pawn structure anna not the
worst thing in the world but not what
you want to see yes this was
unfortunately and not an easy decision
knight d5 i thought it was difficult to
spot i was expecting the bishop going
back to g3 just to maintain the pressure
and not allow
black to ruin the pawn structure of
white on the king's side yet she's still
ahead in development and castles queen
side immediately to get the rook to the
d-file
and you mentioned that bishop on c8 anna
that bishop's gonna have a very hard
time leaving i think fundy will try to
fianchetto put it on the long diagonal
but as soon as the bishop goes that way
the pawn on d7 loses one of its
important defenders so i think that
funny still has work cut out from rook
g1 looks good for chris because you're
putting a rook on a semi-open line the
rook stairs at the black king that would
be a good move
yes and this is a so much more
slow-paced strategic position as in
very very different from the first game
where there were tactics everywhere
yes
she wants to put pressure on on the
diagonal and if she's saying if i had my
rook on g6 he wouldn't be able to
capture so she's thinking of bringing
the rook to the g file all right chris i
don't know where you get this from you
are too smart for me
at the very end so that that is not that
necessary to see ten moves in advance
but it's good that she has plans on the
king's
she's asking why did you do this
isn't it leaving your king alone
and why to that square
and she was f3 which protects the e4
pawn because black has ideas of playing
pawn to b4 but now this pawn on e4 is
defended so honestly anna she's doing
such a great job we didn't love the
decision to play g3 and double her pawns
but that's not important at least not
right now to with the state of the board
here because she has control of the d
file she will control the g file the d5
square the d6 square her position is
better not winning far from it but still
she's the one with the better chances
thus far and she's putting her pieces on
great squares the knight and bishop are
perfectly well developed and covering
this d5 square
absolutely and i wonder if fondy chose
rook to d8 because he's trying to push
d5 but white is controlling the square
with four of her pieces
all these
pieces here
it forces the knight to go somewhere
he'll probably go to d5 i take they take
with pawn they have
isolated pawn that way on f3 i can then
put my bishop onto like i don't know b4
or
i think
right so if i take they take the pawn
i push my pawn yeah actually this seems
okay if i take
as long as this don't take okay all
right uh well now i can start attacking
right
b7 something and then bishop c6
yeah i'm just making the arrows for his
moves here i think that's a very
difficult thing to lead with a heavier
piece because we're told to keep our
pieces close to ourselves so we don't
lose them but rook takes d5 had a direct
threat on this pawn on e5 here and it's
actually very difficult to defend
because if you play pawn f6 you expose
your king to a discovered check that
would lose in the spot
just to show that rook takes d7 uh-oh
can't take that rook there because it's
a check and if you play it and set d6
then the rook comes over to d1 and you
double in this file and down goes this
pawn on d6 so i think rook takes d5 was
a great opportunity anna but i
understand why she took with the bishop
here it attacked the rook in the corner
and keeps everything nice and tidy
let's tune in with her stream because
i'm curious if she still wants to double
rooks on the g file oh i guess rook g1
is a sign that she at least wants one of
her rooks on that semi open five very
logical
and we'll see if she gets to play her
lovely rook g6 idea because the pawn and
f7 cannot legally capture its pin to the
king so that would be cool just don't
play it if your bishop is under attack
that's the one thing bishop b7 you don't
want to play your rook to g6 and fundy
going with his plan
brings that bishop out and he has
completed his development
it's a very good idea by fondy obviously
that bishop was undeveloped and also the
d5 bishop of white is really strong you
want to get rid of the opponent's strong
pieces
chase them away or offer trades bishop
b7 is therefore the best move here and
the rook and game i think that would be
fairly equal
especially especially considering how
there's gonna be less tactics and less
less um
blunderable moments i think that would
be a composition
yeah there's one cool trick here in the
event of a trade rook d6 is a double
attack that doesn't look like a double
attack because a6 is clearly under
attack but this rook doesn't just attack
g7 it pins the pawn to the king we need
to remember that so the pawn actually
cannot legally capture which means the
h6 pawn would also be under attack so
there's an opportunity here for chris to
get her rooks in the game uh if she's
able to see it but instead she went pawn
a3 which is a fine move offering a trade
and then after bishop takes she should
still take with the
rook i wonder if that's what her idea is
or will she take with the pawn instead
hovering on the rook
seems to be that she wants to stick with
the rook
and that's the better choice
he's going to do something strange to me
i don't want this i'll i'll trade i
don't care
she does care that what she doesn't want
she doesn't want to blunder anything
great though
again don't speak spanish but i can see
the move she's hovering over doubling
the rooks on an open line
and her rook is going to be active
yeah very good choice indeed she in the
end said no i actually prefer you take
you take
and then my record
this is saying probably it will be a
king and pawning game
well i hope she's been watching some mr
beast because mrs showed us that in
these end games you need to bring your
king into the picture
in the event of some trades maybe one
may both rooks she'll need to bring her
king up and use it as an attacking piece
i wonder how fun they will react because
it's a difficult moment for him there's
so much pressure on the d5 the d7 pawn
hanging
all right yeah probably
and he takes
she immediately takes back with the
brook
great choice and fondly pushes d6 to
guard the e5 pawn
and
well she needs to win if she had one
advantages if i draw i think i still win
right because that's a draw half a point
it's exactly funny no that's exactly
what i'm saying because i did funny
it's still good so if you go back and
forth on these pawns it's still good for
me
oh fondy you were having some television
what a player though
she is actually ridiculously good
oh my god that that is a true sign of
another great player though when they
acknowledge
how the opponent has outplayed them in
the previous game fondy was saying he
didn't deserve to win the first game
he's very well aware that navidad joe he
will move on to the next stage but the
game is not over they are both bringing
the kings in
and fundy's king has an easier attack
because it's pawn's on h5
so for chris she can play the move h4
herself to try to take away that square
or she can bring her rook back to d5 to
attack this pawn and
funny's okay with the drunk she's
bringing that king in anna she's trying
to get the king all the way to d5 at the
same time fond is also going for the
kingside pawns this is going to be
a competition who is faster will will
this d6 and e5
something 22 happening
i think chris are just saying you take
mine i take yours and let's see
oh she is she's thinking she should have
pushed f4 earlier
what are you doing i don't understand
you no
friend i don't know what you want
so i'm gonna take the phone
and now i'm going to go for your rook
but she could have pushed upon instead
she had the seat passport already
[Laughter]
what am i doing she's saying
no
no no there was a check right now it's
not a check
i don't know what we are doing
so i'm going to hide myself
then he will take my h pawn
i think she lost the thread there but
she had a chance to start pushing the c
pawn after she captured the d6 pawn she
had a passport there that was a
promising pass pawn
yeah in fact the king was in a perfect
position to usher that pawn across the
other side and get a queen so you see
the evaluation bar heavily in her favor
and then as soon as king c6 was played
fundy finds probably the only move
because her throat is king to b7 rook c8
check and it takes the pawns a great
find by fundy unfortunately for chris
her advantage is slipping but this is
anyone's game and she has a past a pawn
and her rook and king are in pretty good
locations
it's just a pity that she felt the need
to hide the king because by hiding the
king it means that it's in front of her
point and to put the rook back and i go
back i can go back and forth and win
a lot of that funny things about how to
draw the game
you're saying if the rook goes back to
a5 to defend he'll play rook back to b2
to cut the king off and then they'll
repeat moves
right
and chris is trying to not repeat she
wants to win no way of pushing that pawn
unless you bring your king in and that's
just going to take you way too much time
right
i'm not sure is she going she feels the
need to run back with the king
she could have tried to push i think
funny played king g3 to avoid a rook b2
check a forcing trade with the kingpin
and then
running but it could have been a draw
still
good for black people put your rook on
b2 i think it's not dry anymore i think
i win i take she takes i go up
yeah i get a queen before
they actually queen at the same time but
he's going to take a second extra pawn
or he might make a draw anna
that's what he was trying to do earlier
in any case he defended so well a
difficult position earlier
all the credit to funding for his
resourcefulness
not so easy middle game where he was
undeveloped and had to be under a lot of
pressure
and now he's the one with the two extra
pawns threatening e42 to trade queens
and there will be no more pieces left
for chris yeah and wow i mean funny he
rebounded nicely after that first game
and even in this game he was in some
trouble but i liked the way he worked
out of it he was making moves the
purpose he said i can make certain
trades he offered a rook train on the b5
sport earlier so i did enjoy the way he
played this game and uh i think that
chris
she shouldn't be upset with herself
missed opportunity sure but
she is a heck of a chess player 509 get
out of here with that ready she she's
so so much stronger than that
i know
i think she'll be upset for the first
game but the second game fondy
he held it when he had to he defended
that could have been a threefold
repetition but and funding was always
aware that the draw favors him for the
match result he was very pragmatic about
it and now it's just gonna be
up to whether we're gonna see a
checkmate or stalemate i don't think
fondy will still mate
no chance and although if he just wants
to win the match the stalemate still
does that
but at this point yeah no no no reason
not to just win the game and he has the
great technique you follow the enemy
king in the exact direction if they move
one square diagonally you move one
square diagonally with your queen and
now he's in deliver checkmate that's it
that's the match
oh my god
what a game
what a game that's actually that that's
actually insane oh my god
what a game and what a match this match
has had it all especially that first
game with the fireworks back and forth
and the mish checkmate we're gonna have
a hard time choosing the play of the
game robert
it's gonna be difficult i think in the
first game there were so many moments
but as we choose the play of the game
presented by eternal.gigi we'll stay
within this game here and i think the
critical moment was in that rook end
game because after
it looked scary for black because
white's king was out on the open one
mistake by chris in a position where she
should push upon as soon as the king
went to c6 i think a lot of players
would just move their king up the board
try to get some pawns but not fundy he
said my rook is passive let's make it
active and as soon as he did this he
turned what could have been a bad
position into one where he has the upper
hand and not only did he hold the game
he ends up winning moves like rook to b2
also very nice and then brings the king
in scores the full point so and i
thought it was a really lovely show and
good calculation by funding the end game
getting queen simultaneously but winning
all the bonds
i agree with you robert but what also
matters is if you guys agree with us let
us know do you think this is a moment
that deserves to be eternalized make
sure to go to
eternal.gg and connect your twitch
account
on eternal it takes only a few seconds
and as soon as you have your twitch
account connected you can type eternal
in the chat at any point of the show
where you think that is a moment that
should be immortalized eternalized for
the rest of chess history with every
match we're gonna choose three lucky
winners that will win three packs and
that's all you need to do type eternal
in the chat at every moment where you
think this clip this moment should be
remembered forever from pogchamps
absolutely well anna and i are going to
take a brief break just so we can bring
the players in you will not want to miss
their thoughts chris may leave the
tournament but she played so so well and
fundy i'm sure he's just taking a
breather now because that was a close
call
in a few for more from pogchamps 4
presented by coinbase
[Music]
so
and we return with both players i am
christine and fundy and funny
congratulations but i have to say first
and foremost chris you were amazing i
was gushing the entire time about your
play if you you know re-watched the
video it was really a sight to behold
you've improved the most out of any
player in polish
honestly like
it was actually i so
i played a game before this which was
against like a 1300
and i won that
i felt like i was playing against
someone higher than that genuinely like
uh this was not to compare with someone
who's 1300 and and and you're 500 i
don't get it i don't get it it's very uh
where is your rating you need to be so
much higher than me
you need to be so much higher than me
you absolutely had me in the first game
and the second game got close as well
it's ridiculous
just saying that she is very upset for
the first game because even though she
lost the queen she still had chances and
then she realized when she analyzed the
game that she had checkmate she didn't
just she didn't just have chances she
she 100 would have won 100
that wasn't just chances no she won that
game in my opinion it's just unlucky
genuinely just unlucky
so yeah she added after that though
funding that she she was she's also very
impressed with your level that the way
you came back in this in that game and
the second game too because uh that was
a very close game as you said fundi and
uh you you move on to the semi-finals
they are
i'm just calling chris's park champs
five champion i hope you guys are ready
for that
funny vouch for that i
genuinely that
funny i feel like we should have a
separate conversation just the two of us
out of seriously learn dutch and we can
do it learn doc i'll try i'll try
but you know you really also have
improved i think people take it for
granted a bit because you start as one
of the higher rated players but you have
also improved throughout pogchamps so
going into the semi-finals you'll face
the winner of five up in sapnap how are
you feeling about a potential matchup
with either of those two um i think
i think both of them are incredibly good
uh i have played five a few times and
i've played saddened up a few times and
in both of those i've won a few and i
lost a few so it's definitely gonna be
whoever it is it's gonna be a match
that's
really tough um so definitely to train
um which you'll probably forget to do
[Laughter]
i'm excited i'm excited to watch the
match and whoever is going to be playing
i'm i'm excited to beat them
yeah
the question sorry robert i didn't mean
i just wanted to ask chris that
unfortunately because it's it's a
knockout format we will not see not we
will not see you for further matches but
i want to ask if you have any
future plans will you stick to playing
chess in your spare time where you
practice further and what what has it
been for you this experience playing in
pogchamps
[Laughter]
this has been an incredible experience
the whole journey in pakistan and that
it was uh another one of these games
where she can fall in love with the game
and get competitive and and feel how how
amazing it is to improve at something
when you are motivated and and you are
working hard on something so she's
certainly motivated to get back uh to
further practice come back to park jams
5 and win it
probably
i i really do hope you keep playing
because
seriously the improvement you showed
throughout this event was phenomenal i
really mean it when i say you improve
the most of any player so genuinely if
in park champs five i watch the games
and i see you with a sudden like a
thousand points and breaking higher i
would not be surprised i genuinely
wouldn't think
thank you
well we're gonna say goodbye to both of
you thanks so much for joining us chris
uh we'll hopefully see you in the future
pog champs and fundy we'll see you in
your next match
goodbye
good luck all the best all of us
wow anna we were spoiled today with so
many great matches the last one being
fundy taking 2-0 but the score does not
reflect how close that match was it
could have gone in chris's favor but he
is the one who survives moves on the
semi-finals and he says he has faced
both five up and sapnet has plenty of
experience against both and he thinks
he'll be a good match
i will definitely tune into that match
as well and i am so hoping for chris to
return for pug chance 5 because she has
improved so much i can't wait to see how
far she can get if she will continue
practicing and be motivated again to
compete
can i say it so many times and i mean it
every single time i am amazed by the
progress she made because i caught one
of like the early streams she did for
chess and like when she was learning and
to see the way she was thinking through
the positions
she will be a favorite in the next
podcast that she plays and she is just
so good right now
it's such a fluid thought process taking
into her opponent's ideas into account
excuse me and i mean seriously but fundy
deserves a lot of praise as well i think
part of it is that we have come to
expect fundy to play so well that we
take it for granted almost that he is
such a good player so to see him
struggle with any player is surprising
but fondy remains in the competition he
remains the player that everyone else
has been talking about in terms of the
favorite but he will have his hands full
regardless of whom he faces in semis
exactly and the consolation bracket too
has players that moved on already to the
semi-finals we have witnessed the match
between mr beast and harry mack earlier
where mr beast qualified to play against
tacto tactum was here with us in the
chat rooting for mr b so actually he got
the semi-finals match he wanted and also
on the other side we see jake who has
won his match against minx and his
opponent will be either rubios
or nick
and rubius needs to win for the spanish
crowd but nick he joined the tournament
the last possible second he's been
putting great practice i see every time
i go on twitter recommended for you nick
talking about his chest experience and
all the work he's putting in so with
anamaya so it's been really good to see
that since twitch rivals but
anna well
we have some winners we should announce
i guess
we do have plenty of winners all of you
who are seeing your usernames on the
screen congratulations to you for
winning some of the exclusive park
champs for pax by
eternal.gg thank you so much to eternal
for bringing these exclusive eternalized
moments to our viewers and
congratulations to all 12 winners and
remember that you can win tomorrow too
if you don't see your name try again
tomorrow because with each match that we
choose
three winners and even though our
broadcast is ending the fun is not
ending ever because every time the
matches are over here we want to
encourage you to play put everything
that you have seen into practice and
join the coinbase community cop
sponsored with our sponsor obviously as
the main organizer and chess.com this is
taking place every time after the
broadcast all you need to do is use the
command coinbase cop in the chat to join
and win diamond memberships as well
am i allowed to play are we allowed to
play like do we just stay on and go play
some chess
anna you know
i've had a great time today commentating
alongside you it's always a pleasure
we've been friends for so long and i
just have to give another round of
applause to the players because every
single one who took part in the match
today they showed their stuff for that
it's not their main game and yet they
play chess in front of thousands of
thousands of people it's nerve-wracking
it's intense but they continue to
impress me and i love the progress that
they made
it is incredible to witness the journey
of each and every participant some some
players have studied chess for a few
months others have been around only for
a few weeks but i think in both cases
what we see is that each and every one
of them feels
so good so satisfied and and uh
accomplished about any progress every
single step forward matters and we have
seen an incredible journey for all of
these 16 participants some of them will
not continue unfortunately we are
already in the knockout stage but we
hope that
all of the players including chris who
will not continue their matches will
return for pogchamps five and we will
before you go anywhere if you are
watching on youtube you will be able to
see the premiere of the recap video on
youtube so don't go anywhere and if
you're on twitch we also want you here
because we always send the raid to
another wholesome channel and i want to
see some blankies in the chat can i
request for blankies robert what do you
think about the blank easy mode i'm
blankies ambassador unofficial i always
welcome the blankies and i do want to
thank everybody who's
been sticking with us and watching the
chess and these fun events pogchamps is
not possible without you nor is it
possible without the sponsors coinbase
eternal gg thank you so much and of
course the whole team at chess.com for
making this work but for now we're gone
enjoy the raid enjoy more chess podcamps
we'll be back tomorrow
[Music]
no
foreign